the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
welcome everybody to day one of Chess
9lx action held at the St Louis chess
club it's going to be a fantastic
tournament and we're all ready to watch
the best chess players on the planet
battle in this new and exciting format
let's go to the studio and start the
action with Yasser and Anastasia
welcome to Capital of Chess in United
States welcome back to St Louis for
future random chess 9 elix
hello everyone I'm Anastasia carlowvich
and I'm here today with legendary Yasser
ceravan it's such a pleasure to be here
yes sir absolutely but those were you
stole my lines those were the words I
wanted to say about you Anastasia
wonderful wonderful wonderful welcome
welcome to St Louis great to have you on
our show this is the first time we're
working together right exactly yes but
that was very near the last time I'm
looking forward to a great show hello
everyone and welcome to Fisher random we
saw in the recently held sinful cup that
the players had heavy heavy theoretical
battles sometimes they just went from
the opening directly to the endgame not
so with Fisher random Fisher randomly
Shuffle the pieces well Anastasia tell
our audience a little bit more about
Fisher random
feature random chess 960 invited by
Bobby Fischer in June 1996 originally
named Fisher random also known as chess
960. named because of 960 possible
starting positions because there are
some restrictions when you Shuffle the
pieces on the back range exactly we have
those restrictions Bishop must be placed
on opposite color squares and it's
important as I can imagine so king must
be placed between the two Rooks so that
we can Castle Queen side or King side
like in traditional chess exactly and
this tournament in this tournament
Players receive starting positions only
15 minutes before the start of the games
okay and who are our players yes and we
have of course Fabiano caruana Wesley
saw and Luca garika Spiro yes welcome
Gary back into the mix exactly 11
aronian chakriama mediara of
the winner of the granchester winner of
everything it seems exactly all events
we had here before and linear Domingos
Peter sweetler who ran from here from
the studio to the plane where you and
last but not the least Hikaru Nakamura
welcome gentlemen and our format uh for
the this event and we have a Templar
rapid round robin uh three days actually
event and time control is 20 minutes
plus five seconds per move okay in chess
960 the background pieces are randomized
this window already a new starting
position is drawn before each round all
boards have the same starting positions
which is good yes for black and white
and there will be a playoff if there is
a tie for the first place outstanding
and our schedule Anastasia
it's gonna be three days we went and we
will have three rounds per day first
round starting at 2 p.m just very soon
and round two begins at 3 15 uh it
follows uh 4 30 will have third round
and we will have Thursday three rounds
same as on Friday we'll have seven to
nine uh round
outstanding outstanding and we're very
very fortunate to have in studio
Christian good to see you Christian
welcome back how are you doing good to
see you guys good to see you Anastasia
good to see you Yasser it's been a great
couple of weeks here in St Louis and the
tournaments were just simply amazing but
I have to say I did miss you uh guys I
was sitting at home watching the way the
singfield cup was developing just an
incredible event but one star that
definitely shine bright during that
event and also the previous one the St
Louis rapid Blitz was at the star of Ali
Reza fieruja just an amazing young young
men coming to the United States for the
first time and what an impact he had to
the standings of the grandchester after
winning the 2022 St Louis rapid and
Bliss just an incredible performance he
was just simply in the zone in that
tournament I was doing commentary and
every time he was coming here he was
just calm and ready to produce results
and after that he followed it up with an
incredible Victory dominant victory at
the 2022 singfield cup he was a champion
in that one after defeating Jan Nepal
miyashi in the playoffs also with after
those two results he became the 2022
Grand chess tour winner also you guys
awarded him the brilliancy prize for the
2022 singfield cup that was just the
best game against Levon aronian his
total winnings stand at 277
000 this is just an incredible two weeks
of business for the young alireza firuja
only 19 years of age and what a trip to
the United States and here in St Louis
he had also he's going to be playing
here in the chess 9lx we're going to
have such an amazing time guys simply
amazing oh it's so good to be young you
know I miss those days yes I have so
much money
and Anastasia set the table tell our
viewers what they can expect from the
first round pairings oh we have really
great bearings and linear Dominguez
plays against versus Wesley so then we
have Petersfield versus
that final game is also interesting
we'll try to keep a pick of Marquee
matchup and what will they be fighting
for over these next three days Anastasia
we have really great price fund I mean
150k not bad at all but the first price
it's going to be 37 500 nice and even
for the last dance place uh seven
thousand five hundred dollars sounds
really great it sure does and as you
were saying at the start of this show
we're gonna be doing a reveal of the
opening starting position we'll switch
to the playing Hall and as I understand
it the players the this these random 960
positions in the Arbiters uh pick one
from the 960 and they give them to the
players before the game and then they
only have like 10 minutes to look at the
position so we're ready for the reveal
if our producers are
we still gonna talk a little bit
um also you know that I ask that you far
better how they're doing it you know
because a special program yes to to draw
the positions and of course it's very
difficult actually to know all of them
yes 960. yeah right possible yeah but
yeah sir I know that you were two times
uh Fisher random Champion right right
right so I have experience I I love uh
the challenge of the chess variants and
uh fortunately uh it's a it's I love
that a lot of the players share we play
a lot of bug house uh in the evenings
here in St Louis uh the players like
these variants and in 960 in particular
when you Shuffle the pieces on the back
ring it very often happens as you see
the players getting ready for the first
round it very often happens you have a
problem piece uh at the opening for
example a bishop on G1 you have a wife
you have a bishop on G1 how are you
going to develop the bishop you're going
to play F4 you're going to play H3 to
get the bishop out so when you're
playing Fisher random one of the first
things you have to do is strategize and
say where's my development how are my
pieces coming out and sometimes you have
this problem piece a knight on A1 for
example it's only going to go to B3 or
C2 so you're not going to play b2b3 on
move one and take away the square for
the Knight so these are the things that
are challenging to the players as they
get the reveal and a Christian they're
only going to have 10 minutes to prep
and that is how are they going to do it
and that is actually part of the appeal
and the strategizing Behind these games
because all of these players are going
to start creating teams of players
whoever they feel comfortable analyzing
you cannot analyze a position in 10
minutes by yourself you have to find
some partners and let's not forget they
are not allowed to bring any sword of
digital equipment right into the playing
hole so they cannot have a computer
around to put the position on the
computer and start analyzing with the
engines they cannot do that they have to
do it by themselves and that's going to
be part of the appeal of this tournament
we're going to have to wait and see who
is going to cooperate with who if I
remember correctly I think it was Gary
Kasparov and Peter as Peter's wheeler
that uh made a great team in the last
couple of years
we see right now Fabiano may be trying
uh to say hi to the Russians potentially
Lanier in the back by himself we'll see
who he's going to cooperate yeah he's
going to be very very interesting
absolutely as we see the players
entering the playing Hall getting wanted
make sure they have no electronics
there's the legend himself
his phones
hanging out you know his tablet his
glasses this is iPhone yeah even his
head
it's pager you know every electronic
device you can imagine you know he's
taking it off and look good people I
mean as we're getting ready for this
round one we're gonna have to make our
predictions early I don't want you guys
cheating on me trying to get ahead of
the game uh Anastasia you're the lady
you get to go first who do you pick as
the winner of The Fishery yeah that's a
very good question I will try I will
pick Fabiano carono this time okay in
the production when we have varuja
nicobia he is he is predicting Hikaru
yourself Christian myself you don't want
to go first though I wouldn't want to I
want I don't want to hear any cheating
any crying I picked Ali razor before I
want to make sure you guys are perfect
look you pick Fabiano Anastasia probably
I was going to go with Fabiano just from
the simple fact that he has some
experience based on his tournament in
Norway that you are part of as well
yesterday in 2019 we had a lot of fun in
that one
um I was thoroughly impressed with
Wesley so now I will go against the
trend I will not pick alireza to win yet
another tournament in St Louis I'm going
to go with Wesley so the reigning uh
Undisputed World Chess 960 champion
uh you took my pick as well I'm gonna go
with Wesley I think he's just a
remarkable player and I there's
something about hit this format this
Fisher random that goes hand in glove
with his style and he's simply terrific
he had an incredible event in Norway yes
he did obliterated Magnus Carlson
they're a matching and this is the
bridge
in the corner
whoa I'm trying to understand what's
going on exactly so let's shuffle them
up
I already started to think how to play
castling in this position because the
king is already on C1 exactly so this is
kind of what I meant about the problem P
so the knights are clear neither three
Knight G3 nothing happening there The
Queen Is Clear E2 E4 the Queen's coming
up but the bishop on uh B1 and E1 the
moment you play E4 the bishop on B1 is
crying right yes the moment you play D3
now remember Kathleen kingside is
allowed still yes the king can end up on
G1 and F1
this is their analysis this looks like
whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah what are the things
and my guess is Peter
I guess they were successful in the last
couple of years and yeah exactly and the
Gary is playing with black pieces let me
remind you and Peter plays with his wife
so it's really we can we can understand
why they choose those sides so this one
is an interesting one definitely opens
up the queen but it doesn't improve the
position as much I would go with F4
actually by the way what is Gary doing
because he's got the different position
he's got the standard set up
oh easy yeah I saw a room oh no there's
a rook on the edge so that is not sorry
that looked like yes I agree with you
but it's actually the night okay so you
just remembered probably this story when
they were analyzing the wrong position
who is Hikaru teaming up nobody he's by
himself he's just bouncing ideas off of
himself so we see Gary and Peter in the
back
E4 he started off with E4 and some sort
of a car con setup well Cruces with
Sam's Franklin and this year he's not
playing that's why he's probably on his
own so will we see Fabiano with laniel
or Wes
so Hikaru just made the move E4 D5 yes
and recaptured twice on D5 but he
brought his Rook out the moment you
moved the Rook of course you've lost the
privilege of castling yes
he's shuffling the positions so fast
[Applause]
the whole t-shirt piece yes yes yes many
pieces so many pieces it looks like the
floating and randomizing okay
um Let me let me just try to bring up
the position on my ball okay
shut okay right now I don't have the
shuffled position on my board do you
have the shuffled I do not you don't
either the shuffle because I I kind of
wanted to show what the players
yes uh shark is analyzing with Westland
by the way last year Chuck was on his
own most of the times so now he decided
to do it with us just to get a good idea
he did just get uh some feedback as well
well he is the world champion by the way
guys this is something that not a lot of
people know because not a lot of people
follow that tournament but I believe it
was during the Reykjavik open when
during the rest day or after the
tournament there was the European chess
960 Championship I'm not sure if it was
official or unofficial but it was called
the European chess 960 championship and
guess who won that I know that I know
the answer
yes yes can I tell you the funny story
please do it happened yesterday I was
actually coming back with the lyrics and
I told him like how do you feel before
the Fisher random and he said oh my God
this format I said but you won the
tournament with this format he said what
do you mean which tournament I said in
2019 you won in Reykjavik and he said oh
yes I completely forgot about it and
it's okay like of course with so many
victories you start to forget some of
them right right right right that was so
funny like how can you forget such
things exactly I think it was a very
low-key event probably the price one
wasn't very significant it wasn't like
the world championship in Norway where
Magnus Carlsen participated Wesley so
Fabiano caruana and I think young
napoleonish as well exactly and Young
take a look at his this young man
sporting his Chicago Bulls to ensure so
confident
so what's he what he is doing is he's
just in his mind he has the position
that you have behind you Christian and
he's playing variants
by himself like he's imagining what his
opening strategy strategy is going to be
and I do now have by the way on my board
as well the analysis board the uh uh
current position and this is what I was
meaning and normally speaking
the players preferred Castle kingside
well that means you've got to move one
two three four pieces out of the way
in order to get there
the crazy part and this is very
important you don't have to play Knight
to G3 to castle that's very important so
what that means is you're likely to
start E4 Knight F3 Queen to E2 D3 or D4
move the bishop out of the way in Castle
your knight does not have to be off of
the square
yeah it's really cool now
the what I see is the problem pieces are
the Bishops so if you play C2 C3 you're
very happy this Bishop's yeah yeah he
wants to take a phone like that uh but
remember you play c2c3 this bishop
starts to cry what's my role you may
find yourself obligated to play F4 and
Bishop H4 in that in those cases so when
you have the Fisher random position your
first job is to identify the problem
figure out how to solve it and Away you
go if you start just for argument's sake
with A3 and Bishop A2 that's pretty good
start that that solves that one but you
might find that your opponent is
occupying the center so usually you want
to start by occupying the center with
either E4 or D4 and then start opening
up uh
the development in your mind trying to
visualize where you want the places
pieces to go after analyzing chess 960
for a little bit in 2019 I have to say
you are very much correct about that
assessment you have to take the center
as fast as possible and we were looking
we came to the tournament with the idea
that we're not going to be looking at
chess engines or anything of that nature
but as soon as we got into the
tournament and as soon as we had a
little bit of time left to prepare we
did open up fire up the engine and try
to repair for the games and uh a lot of
variations work completely insane I
remember one starting position where the
queen was on G1 pointing to the A7 I
swear and uh The Rook was on ba the
night was on A8 and after F4 attacking
the pawn on A7 the best response was for
black to go F5 counter attack on a to
sacrifice a rook and upon after Queen
takes A7 and queen takes B8 and take it
from there try to trap the queen there
are so many crazy variations in chess
960 and it's so unexplored we're going
to have a lot of fun guys
how far they were looking you you and I
both were like what are they doing so
many moves already played it's deep
analysis exactly so exactly so C4 and E4
seem to be the best well at least
according to the engine the best moves
in this position
the players are and this is exactly what
they're looking at yeah yeah the
independently finding that that that
also that idea of just
controlling the center from the onset
you know you see that in regular chess
and in so many of the variants as well
and enjoy this goes to show how a good
displayers are instinctively yeah they
know exactly where to look and they've
seen this position for the first time I
can guarantee you that so we can see now
that Fabi is analyzing together with
Leon right yes and also um
both of them are here so it's American
teams
that's funny E4 F5 and suddenly this
move C3 and the bishop uh is open on B1
attacks the queen and it it attacked the
pawn on H
uh seven and they stop they said no no
no let me just put that on my uh
analysis board I thought that was a kind
of a cute little point one of the things
Grandmasters hate hate is to uh when
they're developing to lose a Tempo like
the moment they see that their opponent
can attack a vulnerable piece like I
don't like it but also we know that we
shouldn't develop our Queen so quickly
right in the game and actually if like
you start moving the queen to H5 then
the Knight on G3
Knight on F3 but that was also uh one of
the things about Fisher random is
sometimes you can develop your queen her
name and because of the pieces and how
they're placed like for example just
what what we just saw a moment ago uh
sometimes it's very hard to follow up
with moves that attack the queen so this
is where Fabi and their team just kind
of stopped and said you know and what
you would just mentioned Queen H5 Knight
G3 and we're getting kicked around
you're welcome to snack on a pond but
that night but if you were in this
particular position pardon me Queen
takes F5 oh let me do that again C3
imagine I go to A5
then you know you're welcome to snack a
pawn but there's another Bishop on E1
yes sir so maybe yeah the E4 followed by
C4
exactly but this is the thing sometimes
your pieces are just not able to chase
the queen and by the way this is a pawn
sacrifice because this can take on age
70. oh yes oh yes the question is do you
have enough compensation
yeah and the way away we go but that's
from the opening of the show that's what
I wanted to say was that in the the
saint Phil cup we saw so many uh
theoretical lines and fish are random
not so much so here are the pairings
again
um guys what do you think Lavon aronian
Gary Kasparov are marquee matchup
absolutely Bobby versus Ali Reza our
backup we've seen so much of alireza and
Fabiano in the last couple of weeks
I think we've seen so much of Holly
razor
and I'm sure we will be seeing a lot of
alireza in the next couple of days as
well but we should start with Gary yes
look look at Gary actually intensity yes
how how did you notice yesterday I saw
you at the ultimate moves Anastasia
Milling around did you notice yesterday
how competitive Gary was And discussing
the position and analyzing it
should be a draw and he is
foreign
exhibitions With Kids versus kids he is
still very competitive exactly to lose
he doesn't want to give up any half a
point right thank you Paul exactly and
uh I think your comment yes sir actually
made it on the first page of Reddit and
there we have uh sorry to interrupt your
Christian genius Dr Jeannie singfield
uh on the ringing of the Bell Gary says
hey man where's my opponent you got zero
tolerance dude he was still analyzing
was probably not trying to imagine the
last and I like the computer predictions
I'm not exactly what's your kind of
caragon this is gonna be but E4 C6 on
the board and an interesting aspect
about this position is that with the
Rook on d8 it almost feels like you're
already castled but that's the wrong
Rook you can Castle short side with a
rook from d8 and with the Rook on A8 you
will be able to Castle long side but
first you have to move the Rook from d8
now when I see this move F4
in order to be able to bring out the
queen
I'm anticipating e for E5 why would I
want to play E5 losing a Tempo in the
opening well first of all I don't really
want to capture on D5 but what I'm
trying to do is close down this bishop
on B8 if I could play the move E5 and
maintain the pawn on E5 the bishop on B8
will be out of the game and again this
is very very typical of Fisher random
early challenges as early as move one
now I actually peaked and I saw the
preparation because spiroff and Peter
because sparov was saying hey man
I'm going to go F6 I'm going to bring my
Bishop out here I'm going to play Knight
to G6 and I'm going to put and Gary was
very excited when he saw this uh chance
to attack and by the way if you play D4
here there is a pin I think yes you
cannot take then takes only five and
then Bishop B5
oh oh oh oh I have to take with this
Bond yes because I can't take but this
bomb there's a bin here yes and just to
follow up with that yeah you're
threatening both uh Knight takes F4
or queen takes F4 Knight takes E5 so
that's why Lavon
it stopped I think he's gonna play
Knight G3 or has he stopped yeah I keep
thinking that he played he did play E5
he did play
okay uh this looks like a novelty
it's not what does your chest I just say
Christian it's not a novel it's not a
novel it has been played in 2019.
in the European Championship no no
virtual 107 versus jar Czar no who those
guys are obviously just database also uh
by stonemaster versus Justin justiniano
five six five quite an interesting games
definitely uh F takes C5 was one of uh
the options in the position Bishop to H5
to try to get the bishop out this makes
a lot of sense right that's why you play
the move F6 now you're not giving
um this Square for tonight because you
also have the H6 potential for the
Knight and land on F5 especially after
white plays the bishop on G3 so Knight
H5 Knight F5 Knight H6 Knight to five
becomes a very viable option for black
in the position I really like what Gary
is doing uh in this one what I don't
like uh is what nepo is doing in this
game a very similar approach
nevertheless it does feel like white is
taking a much more aggressive stance a
much more aggressive stance in the
center specifically E4 followed by F4 C3
to support the move d4 and the immediate
capture of the center with the move d4
and what I don't like is this move H5 by
nepo followed by F6 you're making too
many moves with your pawns and you're
not getting enough presence in the
center and white is just simply going to
be able to go E5 take as much control in
the center push black species uh
backwards also once again you pointed
out at the beginning of the show a very
important fact about this position the
Bishops are the weak pieces specifically
this bishop on B8 in this setup with the
pawn on C3 D4 and F4 I'm going to be
able to uh play the move E5 create that
triangle in the middle of the board that
spear that's uh punching into your
position and the bishop B8 is going to
have huge problems in the ensuing middle
game I really like what Peter is doing
in this one thank you Christian and by
the way I was being completely facetious
when I said novelty I didn't realize
it's so funny
his answer was like you're right yes sir
of course this is a novelty
Anastasia what caught your eye of the
The Games first of all I'm not sure
maybe some players even check this
database and maybe they know some games
I remember is it Sam Shanklin last time
he even checked some random Fisher
positions in order to get the spirit of
the position and try to understand how
to play them and yeah I mean they have
six move looked a little bit strange on
my opinion but I don't know I mean maybe
some ideas are behind and we we're
really not sure what's going on but
right now yes a crazy game Crazy Game is
between Hikaru and Shaq just take a look
at what happened first of all everything
I said about the opening moves throw
that out the window Hikaru came up with
G2 G4 he's the only player to play G2 G4
and against uh E5 he played C3 opening
up his bishop and
pardon me tickling this Pawn on H7 that
was met by Knight G6 nikara said I don't
like your night there
get out of there I'm gonna play H5 and
I'm gonna boot your knight Shaq said
well excuse me
and by the way
e F2 F4 what about your knight well the
knights went back and said I've won a
pawn and Hikaru said no you didn't I
took your knight and here here's the
problem I think Shaq anticipated that he
would be able to recapture and not lose
the pawn on E5 thanks to the pin
surprise
uh I attacked the rook and I defend my
queen so that if you play a move like I
don't know 97 let's say I take this
Motif you can see it in all actually
games this bishop G3 or Bishop H4 move
opening this rook and defending the
queen on F1 yeah I think it's really
great idea many players understood this
motor and what do you think Christian
Bishop takes G6 are we gonna see an
exchange sacrifice well perhaps if he
takes with the F Pawn but that's not the
correct answer just take with the H Pawn
okay played like a normal game of chess
you are thought as a beginner that you
should be capturing towards the center
you should be following those principles
because of course if you do take with
the F Pawn as you showed with Bishop H4
that's a very cute tactic and I'm sure
Hikaru has been looking around these
lines in preparation for this game take
with the h-pawn right allow y to take on
E5 take advantage of the fact that you
have the two Bishops and your opponent
doesn't so open up the center with the
move F6 immediately tackle that pawn on
E5 do not allow white to solidify with
D4 Knight to F3 and things of that
nature attack the pawn immediately with
the move F6 and that probably will be
giving black quite a nice position you
have to look at your king maybe in the
future without the dark Square Bishop
around without the light Square Bishop
around excuse me perhaps after the move
C3 and D4 your king might become a
little bit weak on C1 this is what I'm
seeing from this game so far yeah and
always and always and always you're
thinking where about your king safety
when you play the move G4 F4 H4 guess
what your king is not going King's side
the king is probably going to stay here
on the queen side and if you take with
the H Pawn and F takes C5 was played and
Hikaru started off with this move G4
everybody else started off with E4 right
it was also the only player that was
looking at this position by himself
right so alireza we didn't see Ali Ali
Reza as well yes yeah yes what a
creative play from actually Hikaru I
liked the the way he approached this
position and I thought you know
yesterday when you mentioned that the
white king will not do short castling
what about this Rook when they won
yeah we're probably going to go Rook uh
to E1 and Rook to D1 and I remember uh
Sasha Alexander morazevich we were
playing in one of the very very early
Fisher random tournaments held in
Germany and the opening position he
castled on move one he castled on move
one yes and that's thinking outside of
the box and his Rook was on E1 his King
was on D1 and his Rook was on C1 he just
castled and he said I played D4 and E4
I killed the guy yes uh Bishop I'm
expecting after F6 Bishop G3 let's go
back to uh Lavon and Gary and see ooh uh
we have a queen trade Anastasia see F6
Bishop G3
that moved Bishop H5 that looked okay I
also liked uh Christian's plan of Knight
H6 and Knight F5 now that the bishop has
already committed itself maybe you could
hunt that Bishop down
ah no castling after Bishop H5 Rook
rookie one
yes no castling King site for Lavone
takes takes well no gas linking site for
by the way no castling Queen side for Le
walk now Knight H6 by Gary
C3 opening up the bishop
against and Bishop G6 and D4 was played
on the board which one D4 D4
let's this is the problem this bishop
actually is getting wow squeezed so
Bishop takes no casting whatsoever but
with the Queens off the board White's
King can step into the center and be
perfectly safe now in the meanwhile
I think this Pawn on E5 is giving white
a great Central grip and
could be some Suffocation going on here
like Knight H6 and maybe bishop
h
4
I'm liking what I'm seeing for Lavon I
think oh absolutely and this is
not a great move to have to play but I
think you have to do it because if you
do put the Knight on G6 then you will
have to worry about ideas such as Knight
to F3 followed by Knight to G5 and how
do you defend upon on H7 you have to
lose another Tempe to go Rook to h8 your
position is becoming more and more
passive that's why he played the move
Knight to F7 but now the knights are
kind of stepping on each other as Hooves
right exactly Superfluous Knights as of
now also I have such a beautiful
pressure on the f file and the big
problem remains your Bishop B8 what does
that go Andrew by the way also is stuck
and you need so many more moves to
finish your development right and this
is really throwing down the gauntlet
this is quite the challenge for Gary
this move Bishop H4 hitting the pawn
immediately of course we can defend it
no question about it but then we this
bishop is so very nice place I think
after King D7 E6 might be winning E6 oh
I mean it looks really dangerous are
they going to do one check I'm going to
invade on E7 uh no me gusta I don't like
that them apples
um but to play rookie eight also looks
really yeah I also wanted to say that to
play G5 looks really bad too because now
even though it's it's taken quite some
time
E6 is an option right now wow Gary Gary
he
the only good thing I can say about the
move King D7 provoking the move E6 and
Rook check is this bishop is actually
finally
it's happy it's alive and I don't know
about whether the king is happy that's a
different discussion altogether but at
least your Bishop will come out so I
picked out the engine A6 is actually a
bad move
E6 yes because it's tempting yes the
king actually hides on C8 and I don't
have the light score Bishop no I cannot
attack it on C8 that's a problem Oh and
once again the fact that I managed to
finally give some life to my Bishop V8
is so important
towards the assessment of the position
maybe G5 as well exactly in this desk
wow okay so the provocative active move
six no
E63 I think Knight F3 uh
very much more sedate
um it's funny uh I actually thought
the night was coming to H3 and why did I
think that I want to control G5 of
course but I also want to keep the Rook
open and they're playing quickly now
what has happened uh Anastasia I see
that Knight went to G5 and they're
exchanging the knights on G5 yes
and then 95. I just have to refresh my
board okay so after King D7 came Knight
F3 yes I think so yes or neither three
and then somehow they exchanged the
knights on G5 but first of black played
something what did Black play
um Christian Knight F3 after Knight to
F3 uh the games have not been updated ah
yes but we saw it on the board yes then
we're gonna need a bird's eye view oh
yes I see on the live so
G8
5 a trade yes and Bishop came to C7
makes sense The Rook is ready to come to
f8 and Liberate the night night and once
again you're playing without that [ __ ]
Pawn C7 it's such a big problem and it's
so difficult to get it out because every
time you play a move such as E6 the
seventh rank becomes so weak I can think
about ideas of just simply taking on H6
followed by road to F7 exactly it's a
difficult position but wait a minute
though Christian I'm I'm looking at the
move Rook that's what he played that's
what he played and now I'm seeing like
first of all I have to defend my Rook on
F1 so let's get a king to detour C2
let's go C2 yeah or D2 as we'll figure
it out later but
E6 resign on the spot
C7 that's game over oh how nasty so you
cannot go Knight F7 that's a big problem
you have to lose some time with E6
that is a big problem Knight F7 E6 King
takes Rook D E1 and Christian is
absolutely right resign on the spot
you're going to lose massive amounts of
material suddenly
so let's see if you have enough time to
go E6 because if you manage to go E6 and
Bishop to d8 maybe you have some chance
that's what I was angling for the bishop
on C7 has a terrible life but if I can
play Bishop E6 then I can at last maybe
get get uh to a good diagonal I like it
the question is are you in time so let's
go Knight H5 exactly right H5 ideas of
taking taking taking
um but Knight H5 I think you have to go
Bishop to d8 right uh gosh I definitely
desperately want to play Knight
F7 for a moment I like that move too yes
just so that I can
but I'm the the whole problem is White's
advantage in space he's leveraging this
Pawn on E5 to tremendous effect is Lavon
it's blunting the bishop he's just
taking away so many key squares and Gary
he hates specificity I mean in his whole
career
the most active move you could count on
Gary to play the most active move and at
this moment his pieces are
[Music]
absolutely yes but but I think still
shouldn't be holdable here we check in
on Fabiano and ferrugia because that
looks that that looks like an actually a
normal position and that's what happens
of course in Fisher random the players
do uh normalize but I really like what
Shaq is doing in his game
this one seems to be going towards the
draw right what a lot of
the one between caruana and future that
we have on the big board at the same
time the one that you have on your board
yes you're the one between Hikaru
it's looking really good for black
really good absolutely two Bishops
perfectly placed both of them very
active and I'm two moves away from
involving the rookonate the only piece
that's actually not playing on active
world right now into the game after Rook
28 Rook a to d8 but it has future if you
move the rook and then you can do the
castling still right exactly exactly yes
G's five now normally speaking everybody
likes to put their Knight in the center
of the board that's absolutely clear
whether it would be Knight to D5 or
Knight to E4 but in both cases the
Knight could get tricked uh attacked
pardon me so placing the Knight to H5
where there is no G4 has a dual purpose
you're safe but also you're stopping
Knight G3 by the way this bishop on G H4
is now crying that the pawn is on G5 it
has no future Queen E7 and Castle short
uh what I like so much that it's ruining
stereotypes which we have yes so night
at the edge of the board looks actually
quite good not the one on H1
uh E2 E4 by Hikaru I'm anticipating
after Queen E7 rookie one and if we make
Castle let's see Ah that's not allowing
me to do that that's interesting uh-huh
no you cannot cast like that yes sir
well no kidding yes so how do I Castle
uh you want a castle short yes yes
huh I think it's possible The Rook you
should be out pulling The Rook the king
towards G8 I am and he's asking about it
yeah this is so funny Arbiter Arbiter
that is a viable option yes and that was
a good move a very very good move
because that connects the Rooks which is
as we know always a good thing in chess
complete your development connect your
Rooks prepares to move rookie eight and
Bishop can come to G4
it's easy to talk about an Initiative
for black yes white could also Castle
hey you see that time I did it right I I
took I picked up the King and I put it
on top of the Rook
they were discussing it looks this is
the replay of the long castles
yeah go for it
it's a good move right exactly yes the
king safety the the smile that shackery
are had just there was the same smile
that his King had oh thank you thank you
very much you took care of the king very
good very good you're very cheeky but
that did lose one tempo at least right
he could have played Rook to E8 followed
by the other room to d8 right and have
both Rooks in on the Central files now
after Castle you have to go once again
rookie rookie he's focused on the queen
side though he believes for good reason
the King on C1 is not going to go to G1
exactly that's an empty Square buddy
you're not going to go there first of
all you just move your Rook to E1 so
that's not even legal right you're going
to stay on C1 and most likely you're
going to go long Castle the problem is
once you do that I go A4 8 three I open
up your position on the queen side and
your king becomes extremely weak exactly
like what Shaq is doing and conversely
that black king on G8 is enjoying a very
nice Pawn shield and lots of Palace
guards so yes I think that this is going
well in Shaq's favor let's jump again to
uh Fabi again this was a major piece
ending does look like well just a second
hold on probably is
we thought that Gary was the one under a
lot of pressure let's see one of the
things that's incredibly incredibly hard
at the highest levels
uh is you get an advantage bravo bravo
but then to maintain that advantage
throughout an entire game is really
really hard and normally speaking a
player is going to get an opportunity to
climb back Anastasia I'm still looking
at this position for Gary And I I I'm
not a fan he's going to have to play G6
this Knight is is too Troublesome Drive
the night go ahead if you like and I
don't know if you'd like to take with
the Rook or you would like to take with
the pawn I think where the rock looks
good because then I can bring another
Rook exactly another Rook over and but
maybe black has time maybe through like
I don't know something something
well even this is this is just
but the problem is if you go to G7 I
have enough time to go Rook at fate and
hide my Rook on the eighth rack yeah
yeah I I mean it's a gravel I I'm I'm
not I'm not pleased for Gary but I'm
just saying the current position hey
look if you doesn't look great if you
want escargos yes
at that point let's go back to that
position after G5 sorry just to Showcase
that I'm not only playing with my rook
and my Bishop in that position uh the
whole line that we just oh sorry it was
Bishop f8 I think it was Bishop d8
Bishop d8 King E2 yeah and then Knight
to F6 right Rook takes F6 Knight to d8
yep Rook to F1 we exchange a pair of
Rooks and then yellow G5 yeah and it
looks like I don't have enough resources
right
but I still have my king
so why don't I go King to F3 King to G4
you can play H5 but that's going to
allow me to pick at your Pawn from
behind with the move Rook to H6 I'm not
sure you want that I don't like that
very much so your king is coming okay
let's see let's just play another move
or two seven yes and Knight to F7 and
then maybe I don't know you can I go in
yes with King to H5 once again it feels
like at some point you're going to
actually run out of moves I'm just
moving my Rook back and forth again Gary
is not one of these people who likes uh
solid fortress-like positions but he did
play G6 by the way and then go to F6
which is quite intriguing Gary improved
he put his King back on E8 first so that
Rook F4 and only now did he play G6 and
now if you go Knight F6 and take with a
rook back I win a Tempo yes exactly
because you played Rook F4 very crafty
very crap bird after Knight came back
Bishop to E7
well I must say
Gary's solving his problems could he
have solved them more simply with Bishop
oh no
oh oh
what a craft he does guys guys
Peter just uh made a big big mistake
Peter Peter just blundering I think the
game is close to being done oh no he
forgot
Knight E3 forking by the way this
apologies to the players but this one
went below our radar uh there was not as
many things happening it was quite a
complex battle in the middle game before
this move Rook to G1 okay but somehow
already Peter has been outplayed yes
yeah but so that's a pawn to the good
and of course you can go Knight to F1
maybe and try to hold on but Knight to
E4 perhaps
another yeah 94 perhaps but then a four
pound probably I'm a little bit
dangerous it's looking I'm a little bit
concerned maybe Queen F5 followed by
Bishop G6 uh it looked like nepo was for
choice in any case our first result
Anastasia yeah
uh chess commentator
extraordinaire our our great star what
to do Peter loses his first game but
Johnny bonusi is really in a good shape
here it's actually uh was second in a
single cup so definitely his opponent
was also strong of course his friend
right
um it's also not so easy to play against
your friends but no it's not uh Wesley
so versus Lanier we're seeing a lot of
Contours similar to the game of Gary
Kasparov where Gary is suffering funnily
enough Gary is suffering with a dark
swear Bishop Wesley's kind of suffering
with a light squared Bishop
true it's true
his Bishop is actually patrolling the
open diagonal I like this move G5 too by
the way just trying to put the double
Pawn to good use uh maybe I'm just a
little bit concerned can white
just play Knight F3
at the same time guys compare this
position to the position of Gary
especially the position of Gary for from
a couple of moves ago we have the same
structure right there's no dark Square
Bishop for black there is no weakness of
that nature there is no bad piece also
the bishop on D7 there's no Pawn on E6
yeah
to go out which is beautiful right yeah
it's a completely a different situation
in which it does seem like Wesley
doesn't have as many problems to find
equality as you were mentioning guys
Knight F3 G4 sure why not yeah and black
also has a file right exactly yes it has
a big difference activity down the f
file moves like Rook F4 doubling up if I
manage to double up I'm going to start
being worried without it right maybe
that would be worse at some point
absolutely again let's just jump to the
Gary game Gary look at this he's
actually making some active move for a
change 9 come on
okay the night was no was doing nothing
good on the G3 Square it's looking for a
more active Square
Gary said okay C5 in the spirit of the
position
of French yes with the French players
being so successful Anastasia uh in the
Cinco cup Gary yes you know who is
picking up the tri-colors
and how do we feel about uh the position
in carvana versus firoza guys
who has the easier Drive yes that's my
question
because also Fabiano has five minutes on
the clock
that's a problem
if you don't pay attention if you drop
back
then we can see maybe some activity with
ideas of Rook takes A7 and Rook D7 I
mean of course it's a drug but and
that's what I'm asking maybe it's easier
to make a wife a claim to an advantage
even with a pawn down being upon down in
position of course we know that if you
come to the seventh rank even without a
couple of points it can be still quite
good yes so if rookie 7 is possible and
then
but now maybe just simply root create or
even Rook to B6 right Rook to B6 try to
defend from the sixth rank from the F6
Square
I don't think it's enough I don't think
it's enough
yeah something like this something like
this yes
Rook takes A7 okay how is this position
all right is this I wouldn't want to
play it I mean it's still safe and now I
try to hide my king on H7 right or
I would just move the King instead of
Rook a seven maybe I'm I'm looking to oh
yes oh yes do things like this again
likely draw but maybe black is the one
who's having to solve his problems he
did start with Rook C8 and now here's
the key moment
will you take a passive route with Rook
to A8 I like your Rook a rook B6 Rook F6
there's also Rook to B1 right okay he
played it yeah and that was the one that
Fabi didn't want to see because now he's
gonna have to play Rook takes F7
check
and uh yeah let me just do Let me
refresh my board for just a moment sorry
everybody this is a good move uh so to
win my Pawn back I have to play it like
this
okay so how do you defend the pawn on A7
right now okay you go rookie eight no I
go I'm gonna give you a check right
and I get I think on A7
oh oh sorry sorry
you take an ace right right so you have
to find a way to defend the pawn on A7
so I'm just
[Laughter]
I thought you were talking about the a
bond okay in that case I have to go Hog
Wild and uh and stop your Rook from
getting behind okay you're definitely
not taking that no I'm not munching on
that one oh come on
come on I know you [ __ ]
what are my Christmas uh
good friends list and I think you
actually want to start with D3 instead
of C1 uh so D4 yeah D4 is a dangerous
maybe you have to King of thinking yes
cannot be bad by the way he decided to
go King E6 King E6 right away yeah with
opponents D5 still and by the way that
is a I actually really like that move
because it basically asks the question
if you're not going to come down right
here right now
then I am going to play Rook ASAP but I
will come down right here right okay so
what do you do check
King H2 and now your king is far away in
safety but you're right on estacia Far
Far Away I have a very dangerous Pawn as
well am I not in time Rook takes A7
maybe that could be an issue D3 Rook
exactly where the Rook was A8 okay but
then D2 I'm not in time I'm actually
nice I'm getting checkmated first that's
a problem but I like your optimism
maybe
ah King F1 and now
he could play Rook to C6 and then you're
going to have to take the G Pawn Rook
takes A6 Rook takes G7 and that's
probably going to be the draw
okay
something like King E5 and you just like
King F6
well I was thinking
yes to to at least intimate that my king
is going to escort the pawn up the board
we know it's not going to happen because
there are checks from behind but at
least
yeah to show that you know I've got some
ideas back to our game of Gary was Gary
breaking out of his prison cell uh
Christian he was indeed up to a certain
point but right now after taking on D4
and Bishop takes D4 it does seem like
once again it is white who is on top
because I do have a lot of avenues for
my night specifically I see this Rook
from F4 potentially being exchanged and
then a knight lands on F4 with
devastating consequences because I'm
attacking both your weaknesses on E6 and
H5 at the same time I also have this
idea of improving on the queen side as
he's doing right now Levon that is but
one player that is in deep danger of
losing his first game is Hikaru Nakamura
in his game against chakra so maybe
let's take a look at that let's jump to
that because we said that White's King
was going to be on the remain a
tremendous attack exactly and we left it
a few moves back but we knew what was
coming we knew that with White's King on
the on the queen side uh black actually
gets a free role his throw throws his
Pawn forward and whites pawns are
actually pretty nicely blockaded
absolutely he played the move Knight to
D4 so Bishop 59 D4 and now there's a
exchange sacrifice uh the beautiful uh
Bishops
where I think it was the Fabi game Fabi
against Hans Neiman where we saw a case
of the beautiful Bishops
um here this bishop on H4 is not a
beauty
in the game uh is not is not beautiful
uh I love her I really like this move I
love this exchange sacrifice for Shaq
Christian by the way after the move A4
okay I know it's not going to happen
but think about some Rook to C1 sure
exactly and then I have moves such as
Queen to B3
take my queen please take my queen
you don't want to go Queen to B3 but I'm
just saying that it's a beautiful
possibility I think what he's focused on
after this movie for him what he should
be focused on is the Pawn on D4 so
soften up the king's position with the
move A3 first
move B3 and then
hunger down on the pawn on D4 with the
move Bishop to B6 okay Bishop B6 Rook to
d8 that Rook is not doing anything it's
going to be very difficult for white to
defend that pawn on D4 so something like
Rook C1 you say go for A3 right away
three first yeah you're trying to break
through and then after you've softened
Up The King's uh position go for the the
bishop to beat that looks really good
and by the way Knight to C4 Rook to C4
oh who intake C4
the nice tactics are coming along just
fine by Spidey senses tingling here
it looks beautiful I don't like it I
don't like it I like it for a shock but
it's not like it for Hikaru probably he
is also not so heavy with all he's
always in trouble I don't see okay I
tried Rook C1 that was a fail but
with these guys all sitting over here
that's that that's terrible let let's
try to do something like night so at
least in this case if you do go for the
same line as it before at least in this
case I do have a possible Defender sure
but then maybe I do have Queen to D5
right
how do you define Queens you want you
lose the Knight on e4 I I you're
absolutely I guess you you still have
Knight to C5 at that point so let's keep
going oh Knight to C5 sorry the queen on
G2 is hacking yeah no maybe you start
with Queen D5 just to make sure that
make sure because if you start with
Bishop oh then your knight C5 that's
Christian that's smart yes then it just
just in the nick of time but if you
start with that Queen D5 now I'm
oops and by the way Hikaru is down to
last minute and 30 seconds are going
well I'm gonna just check in on the oh
he played that move Knight E4 ah Lavon
and Gary
nice
face broke through pretty much the way
you described it Rook take the Knight
went to F4
and
Gary Rolanda or something oh
Bishop d8 he allowed a cute chick the
position was already extremely difficult
at this point yes you can go Knight to
d8 and try to survive the problem is
that guy has so many weaknesses exactly
so many weaknesses and
it was a very strange game because that
pawn on E5 which landed there very early
kind of dominated uh
the game because Gary's pieces were
passive from the get-go yeah
estimate really correctly that this is
well play its role in this game
absolutely and let's go back to hikaru's
game guys because I think we're going to
see some resignations in that one um
Queen to D5 was played after Knight to
E4 now he's combining a couple of
threats not only that you have this idea
of A3 and attacking on the dark squares
but I have a second Bishop as well I can
go Bishop to E6 as well create the
battery and attack on that side now that
I set up uh the pin on the long diagonal
A8 H1 fortnite on e4 the Knight on e4
cannot move Bishop to F2 was played but
after Bishop to E6 I think it's
resignation time you can go Knight F6
and exchange the Queens but you're not
going to play foreign
D3 it's a kind of a humor joke not so
bad because you were threatening to play
Bishop to E6 right after you you play
Queen B3 and force the capture of the
Queen Bishop E6 Right Here Right Now
versus forces white to give up a knight
essentially right
I don't think and and not only that
you're not even taking my knight back on
F6 right yeah I really like this idea of
taking with the Knight instead of taking
with a pawn maybe you have to worry
about some sort of attack on the H file
but it's just too slow too slow too slow
uh but that Knight on H5 makes us a
magic transfer to the Central Square D5
king of Faith f8 No no no no I don't
want your knight wait a minute I don't
want no no uh no night I want your king
look at that move by Shaq Bishop E6 deal
with it he says you know what maybe you
know the funny part is that it doesn't
change that much right because now you
don't have Knight F6 but you also don't
have a good way to quickly get rid of
the pin and set up a defense on the pawn
on A2 it doesn't spoil the advantage no
not at all I'm actually thinking
that's really the strongest move I love
that move King f8 I don't want to win
your night I want to win your king and
it also has the shock value because you
could see Hikaru lean back in his chair
wait a minute king of Fate I did not
calculate this right it's a very
unpleasant move to play right when your
opponent already suffers 10 seconds
Anastasia 10 seconds he has to find a
magic trick six seconds five seconds
Queen to H1 can you imagine Hikaru
losing on time no no Bishop E6 Knight C3
is of course is the only move uh Bishop
okay
God be good this cannot this is overall
B3 a b
now Knight C5 rookies it's very nice yes
very nicely Blake yes oh it'll be two
Checkmate is coming that was a beautiful
finish by uh Shaq reminding you guys uh
what a strong place yes
also we have by the way three results
three wins no draws that's one of the
things about Fisher random the number of
draws yeah that is awesome the moment I
speak the commentators curse I I was
about to say the name
maybe our first draw an assassins the
most practical choice for linear is to
just go into F3 he has only five seconds
left now five seconds yes yes he plays
on the draw agreed with a repetition
let's quickly go to the remaining game
ooh this is a very unusual three versus
two ending you don't get this every day
no
I don't think anybody's risking anything
right
to G7 if you take on G3 Echo F5
okay I just stay on the G file I don't
think you can make any progress five
what a cute move
because after rookies
you can actually lose the game I thought
the idea of Rook there was to make the
silly move Rook here you know it's kind
of a mutual zuk Swang as soon as you
move your Rook I can attack the G6 Pawn
but I like the variation of Christians
yeah I like that one as well I like G7
King takes K F5 and based on the same
Motif I guess I can just go Rook to H6
as well so Rook H7 on the board it looks
on the Stars here like we're gonna see
three decisive uh games and two draws
and uh sad to see Gary going down
uh as he did but he he never got out of
his opening
issues exactly yes and so far not so
good for the couple Gary Peter at the
moment both of them lost their games
right but I'm sure they will be better
next time
just the first round and anything can
happen
and perhaps Hikaru should be teaming up
with Ali Reza
there's someone Alice is because that G4
was a little bit dubious
on move one definitely had some
practical value right but a bit dubious
from an objective we do see King G4 on
the board by Ali Reza well well if I
would play Rook G7 I wonder yeah I how
about Rook
one moment we have F5 with the King now
we have F5 uh Rook H3
he was going to do I thought that I know
why he played this move too much
exactly the training has been working
not a fan of it
it's still a draw obviously yeah but it
just goes to show that well now I go
Rook H4
too much foreign
until
how we said the naked people still naked
King is going towards day seven
strategic yeah
draw
I actually did that once I have played
the naked Kings and my opponents my
album reached across the sand I said
move
and we have a three-way tie for first as
we have three winners in this opening
round one
and uh we're gonna take a short break
but before we do Anastasio what's the
story with Cube Boutique today yeah we
have a special chess board right that's
why it's great to support you so yeah
sir can you show us yeah they were
featuring the premium when you roll up
board featuring the official 9lx logo
with gold and cream squares it's perfect
for one to go and traveling and now it's
available in our online cubic shop
oh it's wonderful I've always loved the
canvas roll-up boards they're
indestructible they're absolutely fun do
the people get a discount
uh five percent friends and family
only if they say your name okay uh
Anastasia the honor roll uh what's our
standings yes we have level Marone and
yaniforms
for early leaders in the tournament all
of them they won their games in the
first round so the first place
three draws or Harmony four drops no
four players four players with half a
point of course so Fabiano Wesley so
linear Dominguez they have a hoverboard
and then the Hikaru Nakamura Peters
feeder and Gary casparov they lost their
first game so that's why they're at the
end of the table oh looking the bounce
back and we are about 10 minutes away
from the next round as the players uh
get ready uh they'll get a reveal and
we'll take a break and we'll see on the
other side of the break
you guys probably know there's a lot to
see and do in St Louis but when it comes
to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from laumeyer Sculpture Park and the
city garden to the stunning Cathedral
Basilica one of the largest Mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing St Louis is on
display all year long ooh now that's an
exhibit
St Lou is always exploring
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
like life
it's what you hear
when you really listen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
standings once again
are leading other after the first round
all of them won their games and then
impressive victories in fact I want to
say we had to draw so four players in a
half point and of course the three
players who lost there you see them at
the bottom Hikaru Peter and Gary tell us
about the pairings and what the player
what our audience can expect for round
two Anastasia yeah Wesley Seoul play
with alireza ferruga very nice great
game shakiramidaro will face
don't forget Trevor won his game then we
have Gary Kasparov facing Hikaru
Nakamura I'm sure everybody is looking
forward to see the match that's for sure
two leaders exactly that should be a
marquee matchup uh yes we will
definitely check this game and then we
have linear Dominguez against Peter
swedler Exactly I was gonna say uh Chris
question as we get ready for round two
and get ready for the big reveal as well
the victories that we saw there they
were very nice they were very impressive
especially levons over Gary absolutely
yeah levon's was a grind he got a better
position out of the opening but he
played a very classical uh game of chess
he got more space in the opening out of
the opening and then just grinded down
the end game created a second weakness
on the queen side as we've seen with
that expansion A4 B4 and basically just
uh giving a job for The Rook on B1 that
was just trying to find its place in the
position that was very very nicely done
by Levon definitely cranked up the
pressure and unfortunately for Gary it
was a difficult game from the get-go and
he was unable to withstand the pressure
but I have to say most impressed with
chakra yar's exchange sacrifice that
Ruth takes D4 was so beautiful and so
well timed group takes D4 A4 the
follow-up was powerful as well and very
well calculated if let's take a look at
that one actually because I need to
point it out exactly I do want to point
out that who takes D4 was just so
beautiful let's take a look at that yeah
don't give a chance to track you know
take only for A4 a very very nice move
right you might be looking at ways to
maybe bring this Knight back Knight to
fortnite to D5 but what you should be
focused on in the position is open up
the king get to the king the way to do
that is to take advantage of the newly
created weakness on D4 But first you
have to weaken the king with the move A4
he understood that and well basically
that's all she wrote after that Hikaru
did not have a way back into this game
right and especially we Anastasia and I
we love that King f8 is the game and
here we get getting the big reveal as
the players are already hold on who is
that at the very bottom well Hikaru
is not in the best of moods uh Anastasia
he's not but we could recognize him
because of chess pieces all around yes
at least he carries trying to get closer
to alireza uh maybe he's opening up the
discussion for a partnership in the next
few rounds I don't think that's a very
animated discussion going on there I
mean by the way when they played in
Saint Louis wrap it at Blitz both of
them also were kind of lonely compared
to the other players who were chatting
with each other so normally they didn't
participate in all those shots most of
the times they were on their own okay
yeah sir what do you think of Ali Reza's
shoes can we zoom on alirez's shoes I
don't know must be the sneakers you're
right they do look like you know they
could give a lift did you see these type
of shoes back in the old days yesterday
yeah they were these are Jordans and we
wore them on a basketball court but they
have holes in them you see ah these are
like they have holes here
Grox what do they call those
oh I don't think they're crops
there's something they're very stylish
they're very very silent very stylish
nice nice
look comfy they definitely look comfy I
mean it's very important when you're
sitting at the board you know to to
enjoy your comfort you don't want to be
disturbed by you know tight tight boots
or something like that but we don't have
another t-shirt from Hikaru remember yes
we do we have a pineapple t-shirt
there's some pineapples on there if we
zoom in there's some chess pieces I
think this is a very special uh handmade
and probably custom made for Hikaru
because there's pineapples and there's
chess pieces yes I don't think there's
any other brand pineapples and chess
pieces outside of Icarus brand you can
see the pineapple there okay the yellow
ones it is getting ready for the reveal
he's getting what kind of stood out for
you uh in this first try I mean it's
opening round you got the Jitters you
want to get into the tournament you know
play your way into safety whatever yeah
no I think all players are really
enjoying this type of Chess and they
really would like to show the best of
them like the creativity everything they
have and what is important to remember
that they didn't need to spend time for
the opening preparation so they just
keep happy and fresh and they've got
their new position yes uh the reveal has
been oh look at this it's a three a
three players sitting down in this
position 138 and C8 Queen in the corner
that's okay
and let's uh let's shuffle them up
here we go okay
um the problem piece Anastasia what for
you when you look at this position
stands out in your mind is the problem
piece I remember from the last year that
when the queen is on the corner at some
point it you can really need it for your
defense sometimes you remember this game
of Wesley saw a sacrificing his Knight
on F6 it actually happened because
Maxine Queen was on the 8th and he
couldn't really put it in the game yes
so maybe sometimes this queen can be a
problem but probably you have some other
problematic pieces right but with the
queen on H1 oftentimes you going to be
playing H4 G4 so you start to think that
also The Rook on G1 is a big indicator
that H4 and G4 exists and that means
you're castling
Queen side but then you've got these two
Bishops again the bishop on B1 a little
bit of an issue you're gonna have to end
up playing c three or C4
and there you see Gary playing B3
and you were talking about the kind of
how uh Hikaru and alireza I isolated
from the other players it seemed to me
that Victor korchnoy would be going to
these tournaments
and Victor would oftentimes be the
outcast if you will the person standing
on the edges whereas Michael Tall would
be in the center
everybody would be talking with Michael
Tall about anything and Victor would be
like listening with half a an ear an
assassin yeah I think level Narnia is
now replacing Michael talifa can say so
you know always when he's there
he's chatting he's enjoying the
conversation and we are also enjoying
absolutely
and you can see how they Place
themselves at the board mama is playing
white nepo is playing white Wesley on
the other hand he's actually also
playing white so that's right
they can't all go over the door it's the
right side of the table right but maybe
Wesley because I think he was doing the
same thing in the first game as well
maybe he just feels comfortable looking
from both sides of the board especially
in just 960. I have problems looking at
the Berlin from different sides of the
board if I'm not used to it I cannot
imagine how difficult it is to see a new
position and uh well you have to play
with the white pieces but look at the
position from the black side and prepare
for it exactly you know what I'm always
trying to pay attention to is like which
pawns are not protected or not protected
well exactly try to understand which
which from the opening position
and indeed from the starting position in
regular chess we always say
are the weakest pawns because they're
only protected by The King and I hear
exactly what you're saying Anastasia uh
again is a problem and what would you
guys what would you guys prioritize
actually because I see two styles of
analyzing the position as you can see
Gary has not moved a single piece right
they're analyzing it very narrowly right
but on the other hand in the game
between nepo and Wesley and shock they
were looking at the position that was
already at move 10 and they were looking
for Pawn sacrifices and things of that
nature they're definitely analyzing the
position very differently potentially
looking at the middle though and that's
just really yeah I mean you you have
people who are natural kind of
gambitiers Slash attackers they don't
mind giving up pawns for early
development and I do like Seth a little
bit right now and now they're starting
Anew I do like that opening move C2 C4
for another completely different reason
is to put the bishop on e4 remember you
have a queen on H1 yes and you play G3
you have a battery suddenly yes by the
way I was just gonna say
I think uh blindfold chess is a terribly
difficult challenge I'm in awe of my
colleagues that can play four and six
games ten games of blindfold at once
blindfold fish are random no
zero zero zero chance I think they could
do one I'm not sure even if simultaneous
exhibition was Fisher chess
just absolutely not happening for uh for
for me anyway
um and there you see players they have
fun it's nice to see them like that you
know they're I think they're happy with
this type of chess for the very simple
reason as you said they don't have to
prepare they can just enjoy themselves
they're not waking up at six o'clock in
the morning fearing that their groove
all of a suddenly there's a novelty that
was played in the Bundesliga over the
weekend and their favorite variation is
under duress they could just play a new
position exactly can I ask you one
question yes sir I have a tricky
question for you to create and for
Christian too yes so who said this
phrase of course if people do not want
to do any work then it is better to
start the game from a random position it
was this squad was in 2001.
people who do not want to do any work
then it is better to start the game from
a random position of course describing
so insulting it sounds like it could be
coaching
I will go with Gary you're gonna go with
yeah
actually our viewers can also think
about it and the second phrase random
same person random chess let's let me
enjoy myself and get publicity for chess
without having to disrupt my life for
months of preparation same person said
it bad in 2018.
also Gary it's definitely not Victor
Christian is right actually can you
imagine get coach noise saying that Gary
says 2018 was yeah well I mean now that
he's retired he's playing for a fun uh
this is actually perfect for him because
he doesn't have to prepare himself and
get up to date with the latest of theory
that would be too much of a challenge so
yeah the first phrase of course we can
again understand why he said this right
because he was working on just so much
probably more than anyone else in the
world exactly I mean his preparation I
mean it was legendary Right absolutely
yeah I remember just one kind of insight
that I had with Gary I had gone to
Moscow this was for the Russia versus
the rest of the world and Gary and I uh
played Blitz we had a blitz match in his
uh apartment
and he had all of these books in Russian
on the bookshelves behind me
and we've reached an ending
and he said draw and he pulled the book
out of the bookshelf he knew exactly
which book and which page and he flipped
to it and he said see draw and it was
the same position we had in our Blitz
match so this was a man with a large
Library who used his Library it wasn't
just there for good luck I mean it was
very very impressive and
by the way uh just as I was asking for
predictions
I think I think Christian you went with
West I went with Wesley yes yes I went
with Fabiano yeah oh a world champion
world champion Wesley so okay yeah I I
went with Wesley I kind of made that
decision before you so rudely I gave you
the chance the first yes sir yeah that
is true you certainly did and once again
varusian uh chose
the car ah yes version yes yes yes he
took the cards absolutely right I mean I
really admire varusian people don't
realize what kind of Courage it takes
for him to come out time and time and
time again shame himself in front of all
right last time I picked up Hikaru he
lost two games in a row so that's why
you didn't choose Gary
I don't want to people who want to hate
me exactly he's you know good guy
normally he will not beat me
a cool thing about this position maybe
we can see it on your board yes or is
that E4 at move one for white actually
already is worse apparently uh E4 for
white yeah
just the movie four what about to lead
to a worse position for a wife no yeah
it's by far the most played move in this
position according to the lead chest
chest 960 database okay but it's a bad
move because the queen on H1 is actually
going to have some problems getting up
yes it closes not only that but also the
bishop B1 so you see there's some uh
very interesting geometry right
so you're thinking Eid how can
Bobby Fischer E4 Best Buy test how can
it be a bad motion so what uh question
is saying Anastasia why don't you play
E4 the bishop on B1 and Queen on H1
potentially
um is blocked yes maybe
some situations yes so I don't know I
must say I like c2c4 for another reason
first of all I'm an English player by
trade
but secondly I like the idea of bringing
the Knight to C3 putting if I can the
pawn on D4 and this bishop is ready to
rock and this bishop is and the same
thing for Black by the way black
oftentimes it's a good idea to match
your opponent's moves c2c4 what do you
think
foreign
were kind of looking at a queen's gamut
accepted kind of position
it sounds funny you see you see that
black Pawn on C4 yes that's that's why
that's how they started D5 C4 I think
pardon me I think that's how they
started their analysis but you see once
again they're so deep into the position
right right I think it's about a
different style of analysis
even though they're very deep I think it
gives some ideas like what actually both
sides are going to do and maybe they get
more ideas you get either for you to
play later on other than to focus only
on a couple of first moves right
uh by the way just to follow I think a
little bit of their analysis after takes
oops I've got something going on E5
check this one out he takes G5
so the idea is that the move G5 stops
Bishop F4 the net and you want to retake
you pardon me you want to recapture
with the queen and I was looking for my
knight to put it on F3
this is a kind of an indication of one
of those positions by the way where
sometimes you bring out your queen early
and you think to yourself okay it's very
natural uh to attack the queen and then
again just because of the Fisher random
position sometimes it turns out it's not
so easy to chase the queen down like
um it uh it just kind of hangs out yeah
and look at this night on the face to
protect an H7 Pawn
I like that keep your eye on the pawns
the training is working the training is
working okay a couple of moves after
this G5 idea pardon me so you want to
play E5 and sacrifice the pawn like that
yeah yeah it's a very uh what if I take
advantage well let's let's wait and see
because I think we're just about to
start the games
and what's more uh do the honors for us
and what can our our audience expect for
around two hours the bearings are here
we can see once again Wesley's Soul
plays against Cellular in the second
round
versus Fabiano caruana Gary Kasparov
against Hikaru Nakamura
has Lebanon and linear Dominguez plays
against Peter's feeder we have so many
good choices but let's use yarn and
Lavon as our Marquee matchup because
after all they are one of the three
co-leaders in the tournament as these
two players match one another by the way
this is a big
big time uh matchup as
I mean nepo is ready to do what Lavon
never was able to do even though Levon
became the number two rated player in
the world for a number of years he never
challenged for the world championship
title for his fans of course of course
[Music]
getting ready for his second challenge
Christian nepo not only that he
challenged in uh classical chess but he
also challenged in chess 960. exactly
for the world championship match she
actually played in the 2019 tournament
uh the finals against Wesley so exactly
the semi-finals no the semi-finals he
won against Fabiano no but then there
was a final between Magnus and Wesley no
right no no no Magnuson Wesley
Magnus lost in the semi-finals against
Wesley Wilson maybe no no I think you
guys are right I think you guys are
right so there was a final yes and I
think he lost in semi-finals yes at that
time yes so Magnus beat Fabiano in the
semi-finals yeah
by the way D4 what I remember is just
crazy score that Wesley won against Me
Yes actually it was an obliteration it
was unbelievable by the way D4 G6
C3 defending the pawn and E5
the same kind of uh not my I was uh
following the analysis of the players uh
we see Lavon not uh Disturbed uh
developing his Queen early because he
understands that White's development
will not exploit C3 but yeah that's
absolutely a really creative approach
the queen on E5 in the middle of the
board nobody but nobody isn't can attack
the queen on H1 though right right
generally you would love to play G4
right sure and get the queen out or G3
perhaps but Knight to G3 I don't know
I'm not a big fan of this one
funnily enough it feels to me like black
has an edge already
like what like like what can you do is
that for real uh I like D5
uh just opening up the bishop and
prepping
um
further development that takes some
squares
yeah I mean also this queen on the five
it looks really dangerous in some
variations if you if you Castle I know
the H1 Queen is supporting the stupone I
was thinking about some ideas with D5
but yeah this queen is actually
I don't think it's doing maybe maybe
there was a vague idea of E4 and F4 and
Knight came to defend the F4 square but
immediately by the way that boy that
came fast cash hassles
oops I think by the way they call this
of the 960 positions this is position
138 so the theory develops
it does because we already have some
Novelties yeah yes A7 A5 kind of like
the Joker piano Knight fe6 was already a
novelty up there Knight fe6 was the
night all the way back to move four
what was previously played C6 and F5
F5 yes by actually one player in
particular played two games uh with the
white pieces Gary 1004.
it sounds suspicious
play this game with the white pieces
twice and actually has a brilliant score
2-0 so he's definitely let's say the
specialist is 138 official random
position The Specialist I like that uh
A5 and Bishop A7 Lavon understood of
course that the bishop on B8 is the
problem piece he wanted it out nepo says
well I've got problems too I've got a
knight on D1 that needs a life and I've
got a bishop on B1 that I'm probably
just going to uh but yes sir how about
the queen on H1 yeah yeah yeah it's
happening with that Queen
I found the latest decoration even if
Knight could move from G3 then 92 would
be Checkmate yeah but Knight cannot move
anywhere that's so white cannot blunder
well imagine this you go Rook D1 yes and
then you go so let's say black is the
move instead of D6 just let's make a
couple of moves H5
Rook D1 makes space for the Knight on F1
H4 Knight F1
thank you finally the 92 is coming you
helped to create this fantastic position
now what you do in at the end of those
those games is you know you say to your
opponent you know
you made it hard you you played very
well it was it was tough tough game
tough tough fight D7 D6 now we know that
the the smothered mate is on tap
um
good idea H5 H4 actually
by Christian H5 H4 maybe it's a threat
H5 definitely is going to be met by H4
right but yeah maybe G5 and an attack is
brewing on the king side right then you
help Queen to get out I like this queen
on each one
but then this once The Rook went to A7
to recapture Levon completely lost any
chances of H5 G4 attacks because his
King's not going to stay in the center
and he's not castling see this Castle
rookie one Castle short side yes and
you're right it's time whether it's H4
or H3 in Queen H2 and Knight E2 it's
time you can't play a game of chess
Without a Queen but that's the thing
right now the position is started
starting to resemble a game of chess
true of classical chess with the
exception that your queen is on H1 right
so you might go H4 and try all those
type of situations but my pieces are
coming well nicely 96 or Knight to C6 as
well the only problem I have is with the
Rook on A7 I really don't like this idea
of A5 the way Levon played but I still
prefer black it might it might find life
uh B5 maybe B5 I was thinking about it
because like to take control over C4
square and maybe sometimes you can put
the Rook you can include The Rook Inside
by moving sieve Pawn as well and using
utilizing the C file yeah and by the way
guys it seems like Wesley is really
taking over in his game against Ali Reza
let's take a look whoa whoa whoa we'll
start from the top that was D4 T6 E5
G for
G5 uh oh I think I think I lost after
the first three moves what happened next
well that that's it that's it DTX C5 was
just played Queen takes E5 it's an
improvement and I think we're waiting
for a move by Wesley Knight to D2 trying
to go to F3 attack the queen or to C4
but
take a look at this so
instead of taking on E5
a very intriguing move
by the engine proposed by the engine and
I really like this move it makes sense
once you see it it's Bishop to F5
right let's exchange the light Square
Bishops but more importantly what I'm
doing after Bishop takes F5 you cannot
stop the trade of the Bishops unless you
go Knight D7 and that's really really uh
passive you don't want to play like that
so if you take on F5
and then I take back with the g-pawn
No No that there's an item V8 there's an
items yes wow
such moments for us it's good morning St
Louis
this is all about fisherman you don't
expect this is to be somewhere I like
the pawn on F5 though it keeps the
knights yes
away from the right squares 96 you
cannot go Knight to E6 and G5 is hanging
and the queen is still blocked yeah you
can oh I think that was a missed
opportunity big missed opportunity still
after taking on E5 and i2d2 Knight to F3
it still feels like white is definitely
having the initiative in this one and I
do like uh this setup with the opponent
G4 and G5 for white because very often
especially with the queen still on H1
and your queen is not on h8 anymore I
can go with the move H4 right and
immediately put pressure on the pawn on
G5 so the prospects are definitely
looking good for the white side in this
one by the way that F5 square is like a
siren uh calling I'm thinking 93 Knight
F5 yeah also maybe with your idea of
recapturing even not with the bishop
which is fine but even with the pawn
Knight F5
uh pardon me the F5 Square I was really
looking good for Western and I like this
move that you just mentioned Knight to
E3 why not and that's exactly let's just
make a quick trip around the stage and
see what we've got we've got Shack rear
versus Fabi this is like one of those
Queen's Gambit accepted we do have G3 as
this queen is looking to tickle its way
into the game
I don't know this looks like a difficult
one again the Wesley so game that we
just seen
we're going to come to a linear versus
Peter's Fiddler again we're seeing
Echoes from the various boards right a
five uh Bishop comes to A7 G4 again G6
in this case not giving up the F5 Square
by Peter uh continuing this is the Lavon
we're going to come right back to it but
especially also the Gary Kasparov versus
Hikaru Nakamura again
wasn't it Hikaru who opened up with G4
first game yes got in trouble
early on yes uh what is going on here
first impressions are that white
has really improved this queen is at
home this queen
yes I don't know it feels like uh Gary
got the upper hand in this one uh
Christian oh absolutely it's uh I think
it's still complex sure definitely
there's no immediate weaknesses outside
of the Pawn on H7 but still I have that
guarded nicely Knight on fa Queen on h8
my queen is not stuck on h8 anymore so I
did get my G5 in it's not as easy to say
that you're just simply winning with
white pieces right now it's not complex
what about this bishop on C1 how are we
going to develop ICD 44 and D4 is an
option Bishop B Bishop D2 in the rather
immediate future the reason I like
White's position I like the structure I
like the fact that White's Pawn on G4
controls more squares in this Pawn on H7
has been split and isolated so like like
the great capablanca you know Pond
islands are important and those types of
things how do we feel about Knight G6
coming in though yet Knight G6 right on
cue uh I think that's a a very strong
move because it
it's a tempo for development that
compels me I have to move my queen right
Queen
I really want to hide my king on the
queen side try to move the Bishops away
and then Knight C6 yeah Knight C6 yes
and then I guess D4 and Z to go D4 I can
imagine both of us are going to be
making great efforts to get our Kings uh
to safety I think 96 was played Knight
G6 was played I think so no that's my
analysis board no but I do see a knight
I think a knight is on GC yes yes you
are absolutely right you know I would
like to put maybe one day this night on
H5 from G3 to H5 but now we have to make
this decision where to build a queen so
you mean I don't know maybe but then to
leave the Queen the best Square now the
other square but I don't want to put my
queen on HD or somewhere in this area
but uh I mean I had the chance to put
the Knight on H5 it probably will look
nice there the other thing again uh by
just leaving the queen he did go Queen H
by by leaving the one day Rook H1 will
uh will hurt the feelings
Queen H5
and
what do you think is it one of the one
of the great Temptations in Fisher
random at least I found is this desire
to attack early and sometimes way before
you've made any developing moves you
start trying to go on the offensive with
a move like 95 maybe it's a little bit
awkward for us to defend the F3 Square
in this by the way guys yes uh the one
through uh no please in big trouble he's
getting checkmated right now who what
take a look at that Queen I landed on F6
your queen is on B2 secluded what from
your defense and H6 is coming look but
I'm I'm telling you Honest Engine the
last time I saw this position there was
a queen on H1 Anastasia I mean I don't
know I only got to F6 but I want
whatever that guy is having for lunch
okay but what if I just simply go H6
when we left we left it about these
parts and let's catch up quickly with
the players so Lavon won Pond hunting
also by the way can't I just trap the
queen with Rook to B1
here for this last move Rook to A5 uh
uh Rook B1 on White's agenda that most
definitely Rook A5 so here's an
opportunity
just as Christians well oh sorry uh good
morning St Louis once again I was
thinking yeah
but hey I mean uh uh blunder alert there
is Rook F1
pardon me Rook E1 to B1 probably just
have to give up the queen with Queen
takes C2 and hope for the best but
good luck with that also picking up the
B7 Pawn at the end that's the problem
The Rook wins upon and lands actively on
the seventh rank
um that looks like a blunder you know it
seems to me what happened in this game
is that 11 was trying to use the fact
that Queen was out and created something
on the queen side a little bit he forgot
what's happening on the king side at
that moment that the white skin came
back to the office let's see so I'm not
sure maybe he could stop all this play
by just playing H5 the movie discussed
with you yesterday
proposing for black to play with an H5
earlier in the game right so but now
it's been really far but this is this
was a very cool Motif I think from the
white side because if you do take on C2
which maybe he missed so if you do take
on C2 after Queen to F6 ah yes 96. oh
sorry because I have to defend the night
yeah right I thought you were going to
take on C2 and give up the Knight on C4
well you can take it right now and be a
full piece up but after Knight G4 you're
getting mated uh-huh Knight there's no
way to defend you can go H6 but you are
going to get mated after Knight takes F7
there's no way you're surviving that
exactly and by the way we do have that
Queen trap and Jan said thank you very
much uh I I'll take the queen after
Queen F6 Rook A5 may be a mistake but
this is what Christian was saying it's
uh black is already too late Knight G4
and Knight H6 mate
on tap Rook A5 and we catch up with the
players we're anticipating Rook takes B7
but once more on Associated let me just
be a hundred percent sure that we're
right about this if he had played Bishop
take C2
Knight G4 I do have Knight G7 not that
I'm a happy camper yes I I got the idea
that two pieces cannot be on H6 at the
same time yes
if you push H6 you go back yes if you
play Knight H6 I go you can get shape
and then what exactly I can take the
Knight so I get that yes and I can also
take this Pawn so I think that's the one
yeah this is probably scary it is I have
to defend the mate oops excuse me and
then I got this or I got H6 so probably
Bishop takes C2 would have lost and he
had Lavon had to accept the loss of his
Queen pardon me
right here he played the move Rook A5
and we are up to date with the players
Rook takes B7 on the board
more bad things happening Knight takes
Knight takes like yeah E4
I thought he no
once again there's no made on G7 so
Bishop E4 Rook B4 so here we may just
want to
take a timeout to keep this bishop Under
Wraps this looks terrible uh
Christian it does it looks like uh just
really material I mean you don't first
of all you don't have a way to actively
involve your Rook on Fe and that's a
problem right right I'm going to go to
C1 kick the bishop away Rook to B1
exchange the Rooks on the B file you
just don't have enough material two
pieces two pieces but you don't have any
weaknesses that you can coordinate and
attack with those extra pieces right and
my queen is still on F6 very close to
your king that's creating some danger uh
combined with the fact that I might as
well put the Rook on B8 at times and
create a lot of problems on the eighth
rack it's not looking good for uh black
he's going to try of course it's going
to be a game but most likely there's not
enough compensation let's take a look at
what's happening in Shaq versus Fabiano
because that's a really funny looking
position it looks like some sort of a
qga or like a catalog on but there is no
Bishop on G2 there is a queen that could
potentially have enough yankado on G2
it's a funny looking position I have it
looks like a chest position but not
really
I like Black's last move uh KR chaos uh
C5 C5 let's open up the diagonal let's
exploit the fact that the Knight on C3
is currently undefended and he's not
going to give you uh time to play Bishop
A3 and maybe stop that move c65
it makes sense I like this move C5
Knight on d8 now finally has the C6
square but not only that you also open
up some uh jobs for the bishop V8 yeah
we exchange the pawns from C5 to D4
Bishop E5 is coming on the board you
might have some problems uh on the long
diagonal I like this move C5 and I think
it's definitely Fabiano black who is uh
to be preferred in this one don't don't
cannot see them move now for a while
like if you play sounds like Knight B5 I
mean then like Bishop D5 like I don't
know what's going on I think it's one of
those five nights maybe things are
Anastasia that the crazy part about
Fisher random yes is it makes you want
to sacrifice things you know like
whether you like to or not I don't know
what I'm going to sacrifice like for
example just imagine I take it takes and
I start to think okay I'll take Queen
takes and now I just need to uh
you know bringing
as many pieces to the king side as I can
and yes you know let's go let's have uh
yeah a chaos this actually looks good
right but what if I after taking on D4
again
what if I go Knight C6 is that a move
In This Moment
1966 yeah but okay now that my knight is
actually defended you do have D5 yeah
that's what I was thinking and I was
thinking
how much pressure do I get if I go
Knight D4 I really like that Knight in
the center
I'd like to have some ideas of Bishop to
G4 to follow up maybe Knight to E2
that's a powerful night no question
about it maybe just play for initiative
but instead you are you are blundering
upon
you must take that pawn on E7
maybe yeah sir this is official random
you cannot be greedy I cannot be sure in
anything
Bishop H3 right in Europe no
remember I was saying that great now but
then you go I can't sacrifice I can't
sacrifice it's a wild position sure
what's happening here I was dreaming I
was dreaming that I could do uh crazy
things on the long diagonal by the way
we do have B3 it takes C4 now the key
moment Knight C6 double-edged or queen
takes D4 uh for uh Fabi this is
yeah that's it for equity for do
something right right it's fun position
to play but by the way yeah Queen takes
D4 I do like this move because if you do
go Knight E4
I think I can force the trade of the
Queens with Bishop G4 right
oh
oh oh oh oh I I definitely needed the
Queens on the board for a compensation
uh it's funny that you don't have any
squares actually you can go Queen H1
back or queen G2 of course
I just came from H1 are you sure I would
I don't know if I want to go back uh
Queen takes D4
I played well boy I need need help on
this one uh Anastasia I'm not uh I'm not
quite feeling this position for white
just it okay I just understand that yeah
it might be free but then C4 C4 is nice
something is wrong right with the
position yes yeah it's not us normal yes
it looks normal but it's not us there's
just something wrong with the position
we're we're going to complain uh to the
producers of our show like Bobby Fischer
as well how dare you do that now what
happened with uh the game between our
two leaders when we left it um
Lavon had got his Queen trapped
and ah look he won back an exchange but
boy he had to give a shed
two Pawns
uh doing it his strength is some sort of
uh
Fortress yes
E5
and that's the reason why I don't think
he's going to work specifically for her
Rook rookie three E3 I think this is
prepping obviously we would love to have
our Rook far more active so he's going
to stop that of course he's going F4
he's trying to F4 already go Rook to H3
and maybe Checkmate on the H5 well
you've got to play for the dark squares
because the lights were this bishop
is doing a fantastic job yes defending
F7 but more importantly stopping you
from advancing your passer so you've got
to start introducing a different front
uh f 5 F6 I think uh still work to be
done but I don't like the way he plays
it Rook to E3 very nicely defending the
pawn on C3 there is no entry on the C
file for earrings it just feels like a
very controlled demolition of Black's
position right now very nice let's jump
to Gary and Hikaru and we left it by the
way what's the times of the player's
Anastasia yeah I think Gary is down to
five minutes at the moment which is like
Hikaru is noted for his extraordinary
skills and when he's got the advantage
on the clock by the way Gary done
pretty good I mean the only thing the if
I had only one complaint about White's
position so like my king should be on A1
where it's very nice and safe but this
is yes from a structure point of view
the H7 Pawn is tender
F6 squares very nicely controlled by the
Knight on a G4 so white has his grip but
I like it but the only question is what
if black
plays a role of a spoiler and tries to
break out again that King on E1
if you don't play E5 by the way I think
you're just going to die
some horrible slow death Christian jump
in let's take on D5 after E5 yes
take on D5 why not
I mean you can think on D4 but I think I
think back and that's a check so that's
a check oh my gosh so does it mean I
have to preface no you can continue you
can take on D4 maybe it's not that bad
I do have some really oh but Queen H2
might be a problem really Queen H2 if
you take on shoes before I have not only
Queen C7 but also Knight B6 mates
there's a lot of mates coming on the
board that is uh ah and you don't have
Knight E5 because then I just simply
take only five and the beach Pawn E7 is
hanging right yeah this is uh dope
that's an overloaded it's overloaded not
at night on C6 there oh that's Queen H2
yeah it was a beautiful move actually
yes the queen is
jumping on the queen side oh does that
if if if Hikaru has to play
we would say miserable the miserable
mover of G7 I mean this is just uh
wonderful is Queen takes H7 a threat
uh-huh
to ask every time somebody's threatening
anything so for example King B8 do your
worst and maybe I'll do my worst D5 yeah
and by the way he did play Rook G7 I
wrote Justin I think he's on the board
oh very happy Rook G7 a miserable mode
and now we're anticipating get your king
out of Dodge and then once you've you've
taken care of the king then you can
start thinking about F4
and complete control you really have
your grip a positional grip for for Gary
here
and the engines not that they matter too
much in just 960. because the positions
are so chaotic they don't like
I don't like them Rook G7 seems to be
quite passive yeah yeah I would have I
would have liked King B8 in the
suggestion you made their Christian is
it a threat Queen takes H7 I don't think
funnily enough uh the computer actually
wanted to go F5 so you had the right
idea try to activate your pieces yes
hmm maybe a missed opportunity is it
working yes it definitely works
just to check I think you've permitted
to go to the Arbiters just one small
detail Yes actually it took place some
time to understand all these rules
yesterday they were analyzing for quite
a while right yeah do disgusting on that
one and okay we do have Rook D7 on the
board we do have a passive position Gary
looks in good shape what about not in
good shape on time yeah and that might
be problematic he's dropping down to his
last four minutes right now I think this
is actually the problem as you get older
and your understanding of Chess is
really really great but it's tough
making these executive decisions I don't
think it's necessarily uh a getting
older thing but actually not being
active because you see viciana right
he's fairly active he still plays fast
he still plays according to his
instincts
I mean his instincts are definitely
right on par with the greatest out there
right but he's not as active so maybe he
doesn't trust his intuition as much and
especially couple that with the fact
that you're seeing completely new
positions from the get-go right well it
becomes a difficult task exactly and
here he is uh Anastasia you see ooh
maybe that's why he could have played
three seven maybe he feels that it's
difficult for Gary was it to play moves
actually H3 I thought about maybe the
idea before but I was a little bit shy
to propose it oh don't be shy but maybe
it's a different idea maybe a three is
just two we have two ultra aggressive
Grand Masters on set ready to jump A3
I wanted to play before but it's not
possible without this week okay clearly
Gary played
A3 with the intention of playing Bishop
C2 and preserving the bishop that's it's
a change I was thinking Bishop C2
inviting night before it's all yours I
would castle and go ahead and take the
bishop you were asked to give up this
this light Square Bishop because what do
you have on the other side of the board
you have a really wonderful light
squared Bishop that's not bothering me
in the least but Gary is you know one of
these classical players right he
believes in exactly he believes in the
two Bishops I was thinking A3 was maybe
preparing Bishop D3 but Gary kind of
shaking his head and we have a result
we do have
not a surprise uh Jan with his extra
Queen yes but still like a good position
he actually played what you predicted
here yesterday he moved his pawns
forward and see and this used the dark
squares dark squares this bishop is
great
you're not going to kill you on F7 but
I'm gonna kill you on G7 in the dark
squares well done what a great
understanding without calculating moves
you just said to the whole there you go
and there we have it Bishop C2 in the
game of Gary down to two minutes but
what hikaru's time oh yeah I mean he had
like 12 now he has a bit less than ten
so nine minutes in total huge huge
Advantage it's a lot of six minutes on
time and that's more very common I must
say for for ikaru he's used to uh having
much more time than his opponent by the
way I still even though I can you know
quarrel a little bit about A3 and Bishop
C2 Gary is an in great shape if he makes
a move Castle F or King B1 we have a
kind of a slav
type of position and exchange slav where
white has a grip pretty good Christian
absolutely he needs to get that F4 in
not allow the Breakthrough with E5 if he
manages to do that his position just
plays itself you have a different
position behind you what have you been
looking at I was looking at this crazy
uh game between Wesley saw and firuzha
both of these players are down to their
last five minutes and a completely
insane position so many pieces hanging
Bishop takes G5 was the last move F6 has
to be played because otherwise I'm just
simply going to recapture only for I'm
going to be a pawn up and your king is
not going anywhere that's a big problem
you cannot castle with the bishop on G5
so you do have to take immediate action
and play the move F6 and then it does
seem that after Knight takes E5 and this
has to be very carefully calculated by
both players Queen takes E5 Bishop drops
back to E3 we see the battle between the
two Knights versus the two Bishops I do
like the fact and I have to say I do
prefer wise position the King seems to
be much safer for white right on F1 it
doesn't seem like you have too many
problems you can throw in a check with
Queen to B5 but then I just simply go
King to G2 you still have to calculate
so well in the position for example this
is a really cool move Knight to H4 and
it's the only way to get out of uh you
need to find a way to hide your king you
can do that by going Knight H4 take on
F5 take advantage of the pin on the G
file and then later on Castle which
seems to lead uh to more or less a
complex situation nevertheless you have
to find all of this with five minutes on
the clock as firuza if you don't the
king stays stuck in the center and you
are in deep trouble
great uh you know your guy Fabi uh
played exactly your suggestion there uh
Christian after E3 takes D4 Knight C6
and I just kind of flashed the position
I was thinking to myself fabby's taking
control and look what he did remember we
were talking about the battery the
bishop coming to E4 well Abby got it on
the other side
and as I'm looking at the position
with control I like fabby's control of
the position very much I think he also
has a big advantage on time
check down to his last one minute and 30
seconds yeah 30 seconds right a lot of
pressure for Fabiano box is that as Tiny
as they can make it yes I cannot make it
too
I think they're trying to invoke a
premature blindness
okay okay see it it's only one minute
left there's a nice view there you see
and ticking on the stuff great to
position great play for Fabian I just
said you remember before you go that's
the only thing I could tell without
variations but so it's sending him some
energy you know he's my pig so I have to
do something okay
and who did you pick again
so that's why I got you down here but
actually you know in social media all
the time the viewers the fans of Fabi
they keep saying this all the time like
go father
like cheerleading or something yes by
the way now that you mentioned it you're
here of course and uh on sat here in
studio uh doing uh our poor people on
social media they're collapsing without
you who's taking your place everything
is under control
who is now taking care of social media
so he is a really great International
master and his great experience he will
take care of everything yeah sir he's
following our broadcast all the time and
he knows everything about social media
and to our audience if you uh want to
subscribe to our social media how do
they do that how do they ask questions
how do they Anastasia let them know of
course I mean you can and see this sign
Saint Louis chess club yes so you just
actually go and you subscribe and you
follow our accounts on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook we have them
everywhere so what is more useful for
you just go subscribe and follow the
news Sometimes some backstage
information and videos you can also see
them yes in our accounts wonderful
um just
checking in on the game between Lanier
and Peter again that kind of flew under
our radar a bit just does look like
Lanier is enjoying a very nice advantage
of some extra pawns he's just played the
move E4 has Lanier I assume he's going
to follow it up with F2 F4 even at the
cost of a pawn and some activity uh
White's trying to
well uh win this game yeah well linear
has two extra pawns right so that's
important in in 19 in night endings I
mean it's a big advantage and don't
forget that absolutely normal
and don't forget that linear actually
won this tournament in 2021 if I'm not
mistaken this he's the widget
defending Champion yes bravo bravo uh
linear my job uh you you were mentioning
Christian that Wesley so and farrugia
that one is uh we're playing crazy but
they didn't follow your advice
while they didn't yes
shame on them
not Wesley yeah
he didn't play the movie F7 F6 difficult
move to make I'm not going to lie it's a
very difficult move to make you have to
see this whole Queen B5 Queen takes F5
idea right it's not easy and if you
don't see that you understand that your
king stays forever in the center and
that's not good news exactly so what
you're trying to do is keep the Knight
on E6 so that the king can finally
Castle right but it's not possible and
this is exactly what's happening because
of this move Rook to D1 that Wesley just
played a couple of moves ago keep the
king blocked in the center this is all
that his place surrounding around that
is the fact that you cannot allow black
to Castle and put the king to six but
but now I'm looking at the position how
can white take advantage of the fact
that in reality any trade of the Rooks
black is now ready to make uh a b line
to the king Queen side I beg your pardon
so I'm a pawn up right now yes yes
perhaps even I can trade and then go
Queen three three and try to
and and perhaps yeah because you had
mentioned previously there is a queen B5
check that white should pay pay
attention to right
so Rook takes King takes if you want to
go Queenie three Queen E3 maybe pick up
a pawn but now you'll have some ideas
with Knight to F4 exactly
that's that's basically the good news of
Black's position the F4 square is is an
ideal uh uh it's very nice yeah extra
Pawn but maybe good chances for Wesley
let's just jump to the game of of Hikaru
for a second because once again after A3
Bishop C2 uh Gary definitely struggling
with his decisions
if I was played so uh Hikaru tried to do
something right in the center right he
didn't like probably what was going on
again this Rook on G7 makes an
absolutely atrocious and Lanier and
Peter I think Lanier
yes the extra Pawns
uh and again uh Gary what's his time and
he carries down to his last uh minute
last minute f2f3 trying to break up the
team I like this move I love this move
because this move really does uh open up
the bishop and he captures recapture
should be favorable but once again I'm
still
I still feel like my king belongs on B1
absolutely but you have time together
that's good so Queen takes E7 finally
the queen moved from h8 going to d8
Queen to DEA oh and returned to
civilization that was the idea of moving
G7 because now Queen can go through it
great I'm just not so sure how great it
is okay so let's now it's time you
wanted to do castles followed by E4 ig3
he's going towards H5 or F5 he's trying
to put some pressure to immediate
pressure on The Rook on G7 yeah because
this Rook where where it goes
that's very materialistic isn't it yes
I like it yes
an exchange okay I need to find some
tactics right now for black if not after
Knight H5 I can pretty much resign
yeah Knight H5
the problem is Knight H5 I will be
forced not to lose material take on F6
exactly right then if I you take back
with the Knight my Rook on G7 is still
completely locked in
and you also don't have dark Square
Bishop which creates additional problems
it's not looking good so black should
take now maybe on F6 I mean but I don't
like it at all but I don't want to give
this bishop but maybe that means you're
going to play with uh down a pawn I will
take on each side and then you take on
H7 yes and wow wow it doesn't look good
hmm
this is not looking good then by the way
he's also down to his last perhaps the
only thing I can imagine is that he
immediately recaptured with the queen
he's looking to simplify the position
I can understand that because again the
King on yeah no way you're allowing no
Queen trade King F2 because G3 was was
hanging but yeah yes really King F2 okay
the game is definitely heating up Bishop
takes G6 on tap for Gary
don't forget about that one that's a
nice simplification yes definitely
f8 Knight f8 attacking The Rook Hikaru
understands that
he's he's good and hiding these tactics
he's pink Rook H6 right you just kind of
hang around you know that was a very
good move because again Gary would look
for some trades with the move Queen F4
just getting away from the tickle what
he currently needs to find right now is
some sort of counter play on The Queen
side along the lines of Knight to A5
open up the C file have ideas of Bishop
takes A3 sorry there's no Bishop that's
an iPhone
I was thinking something along the same
lines that you were saying I was
thinking that you need to play like
Knight A7 to B5 to break up the team
probably similar ideas look Knight A5
by the way I'm just getting breaking
news up Fabi this is a very exciting
game we're just going to move away from
it just to take a look between uh
chakriar and Fabi as yes there it is
their resignation we're just in time for
the handshake
yeah good game by five actually it was
so complicated he found all these moves
wow really nice ones Knight C6 would you
want to jump back to the game by the way
three decisive games count them
um in this uh second round and this one
is really hitting up 45 seconds before
he carved 35 seconds for Gary you can
almost feel Gary is nervousness I mean
the board his intensity in his Focus
we're second and none I mean when uh
he was really considered the most
fearsome of competitors Queen D7 takes
away that Square from yeah there's no
more Knight D7 wasn't that the dream
Square for the night exactly to dislodge
the queen from F6 but there's no more I
mean the desirable Knight F4 does allow
Knight takes A3 I do believe this is
what he's looking for
and by the way we have to H1 Rook H1
Knight comes back to G6 Knight F4 okay
okay
he wants to recapture with the pawn
which in order to trap the bishop on F5
which she defended against
clever and
it's been working for a thousand years
strategically it seems to be
Gary's name
and Bishop to F5 perhaps I think it's
Force come on that Bishop is just 94.
okay of course okay
Rook takes G8 there is a queen A4 siding
Queen A4 Queen C2 that might become
dangerous Bravo
Queen A4 Queen C2 exchange the Rooks as
fast as possible Gary yes okay follow it
up
by the way doesn't he have a D4 D5 and
he's looking towards that those
eyeshadows Bishop C3 the D4 check
opposite color Bishops the one who
starts first to attack may have some
Bishop to D5 F5
well one thing that's definitely
trending in Gary sphere right now Gary
cannot lose this
oh
[Laughter]
Okay Christian I don't know I don't know
about A4 by the way I was thinking King
E3 I hope I didn't think
it should be seven we will start pushing
rules no this ending it's not drinking
sometimes B3 I like that just stopping
Queen takes a for the bishop C3 becomes
weak now true true
F6 but now the queen is invading well
there's a queen H3 Queen G4 yes oh my
gosh King takes E4 and we'll see
Queen G2 check maybe I don't know
maybe this maybe Gary's allowed too much
counter play okay I think he's going to
finish in a draw but he's definitely not
losing guys come on
yeah okay five seconds help
right
ooh yes uh by the way exactly Anastasia
there is a five second ingredient
somebody wants to maybe to play this six
and queen A5 perhaps it's time to go E3
in that case
E3 and Bishop D5
yes 23. and Hikaru a little bit that
that was not a very well centered Queen
uh D6 G6
no G6 is Queen F3 check so it's time for
D6 right
this is what they said yeah so we both
saw it in the same time
that's a nice one yeah okay okay Gary's
looking to maybe hide his King on G7 E3
he's trying to give his own checks by
the way she F2 is a Checkmate threat
what you have to address that Queen to
have to you better take it so he took it
but
Garris is trying to escape with his King
but
King E5 King E5 there's a queen is
coming be careful
and queen E6 will attack the uh you you
will capture the pawn on D6 with the
check let's go Queen E3 I Queen what
queen
E3
what's the times what's the times 20
seconds for Gary 30 seconds for Hikaru
is still enough time to think sometimes
but not that much
commentators curse oh
I feel so bad oh let's question
um this is our remaining game of this
WOW incredibly uh exciting round two by
the way oh my goodness I was just a
piece up
no peace I'm trying to count pawns but
it's just
there goes one of them yes yeah but now
I go 95. yes and stops IT you mean the
extra piece is more meaningful
foreign
yes
[Music]
same as Fabi by the way
they drew in the first round against
each other
wow that did it and that means this is
the most decisive round of the
tournament you can't get more no you
can't get more than five out of five
unless we're talking the miracle a
miracle in Montreal where in the final
round the chess bra scored five out of
four
how's it possible
and they made it to the playoff thing so
that result uh sum it up for us
Christian what a what around and what a
blunder by Gary just incredible I think
he uh became too ambitious towards the
end of the the game he didn't try to
defend his A4 Pawn with the move B3
weakening in the process the bishopone
C3 now you have to find another Square
for that Bishop but the problem is once
you play this move D6 you are a bit too
ambitious right because after E3 you
have to be dealing with all sorts of
checks Bishop takes B6 was the critical
move in the position which actually
would have won the game for a wife a
very difficult tactic to see none of the
players uh saw it and the idea behind it
is if you take I give you a check first
I take the pawn you have to go back if
you go Bishop to A6 then your queen
basically doesn't have a job because the
G2 square is no longer protected so if
you go [ __ ] Basics I just simply push
uh D7 I can even go Queen to C7 exchange
the Queens
are coming exactly wow and this is the
key very difficult to see with only a
few seconds exactly truly the same thing
happens if you go King to B8 Queen to C7
you have to trade off the queens and
after G6 Unfortunately they are unable
to stop it and your Pawn sure is very
threatening but I can just simply go
King to F2 stop it in its tracks I'm
going to get my queen you're not and
this just wins the game for white big
missed opportunity for Gary but at the
same time he only had like 20 seconds
but then show us the moment that will
show us the key moment at the very end
because I thought before yeah right well
of course this is gone Queen E3
of course just go Queen to E3 allow
black to take on D6 it's still equal
parts right and my king is actually just
simply protected King to E3 well just
overlook this one it's just a blundering
one move you're missing 24.
and that's nerves painful simply painful
nerves
and uh Anastasia do the honors Where Do
We Stand after two rounds of play and we
have a soul leader in the tournament
the only one who won both of his games
and and now he has two points
they have all one and a half points yeah
what a pack of wolves chasing them right
exactly and then we have live one
aronian Hikaru Nakamura and Shakira with
one point at the moment and half a point
for restless so Peter sweetler and Gary
kaspar unfortunately now have no points
at all at the moment and Wesley so
Christian's prediction not doing that
well
we round three uh coming up shortly uh I
don't know if we have our bearings for
round three but uh definitely we'll let
you know what they are on the other side
of this break
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and we are ready to check the standings
Yandy pondichi is leading the tournament
after second round pagiano caruano
follow him as well as linear Domingos
and alireza future with one and a half
points then the one iron and
hikarnakamura entry who have one point
at the moment Wesley son Peter swedler
and Peter Sweden garlic as part of our
finishing this table not very nicely yes
and what about our parents for the round
three
and we have petersfinder versus Wesley
saw Cleveland Arena plays against the
linear Domingos hicaro Nakamura Yani
ponies
yes I think so because we have leaders
plays against Gary Kasparov alireza
Ferrero plays against it and for Fabi uh
Gary's kind of getting a a bullseye on
his back having lost two and the players
have gotten their reveal and they're
hard of work
trying to make heads or tails and let's
see it for ourselves through the magic
of television
Shuffle
okay the bishop on D1 is an issue what's
the weak Pawn
what's the week
let me check I don't see F2 F2 again yes
the weakest the weakest okay uh break
the position down first Christian what
would be your approach E4 D4 what's the
week before I think it just feels like
it's opening up two pieces my queen and
my Bishop
the queen that's the way I look at the
position I I don't see anything else E4
or F4 Maybe
for the Rooks are perfectly placed so I
don't have to worry about the Rooks uh
the Bishops definitely something to
worry about what I'm mostly concerned
about is the knights one of them sure I
know probably is going to land on F3
right from G1 what am I going to do with
the Knight on E1 that's right the
question but I think for starters I will
play E4 okay by the way there you get a
really really beautiful view of these
House of starting designed uh chess
pieces that are dgt enabled I don't know
if you ever got a chance to lift them up
yourself Anastasia they're triple
weighted they're really really nice yeah
like when you feel though yeah it's like
really uh arts art set but uh the play
this is an art this is competition now
and uh for nepo you think he's a little
bit angry about that playoff
ah yes of course he was absolutely yes
he was frustrated after that game and I
think yes he would like to take a
Revenge yeah something to show I mean
that look I'm going to be playing for
the world championship next year in 2023
I'm a very serious force in chess and if
he can demonstrate that in Fisher random
yeah he could do something yeah
is linear changing teams right now
because I was about to say with Fabiano
and Levon what's happening oh let's see
maybe it depends on the pairings a fair
weathered friend
they were on the license together was
live on right right so now they're
playing against each other so they
cannot do it together
that makes sense I remember Miguel
neidorf had a very annoying habit during
his games he would walk around the
playing Hall and he would ask just
random people how's my position how's my
position how's my position and he ran
into one guy at the coffee uh table
how's my position it was his opponent
you know
dope
no players are not allowed to talk
during the games this has not been a
successful combination
but we can say that Gary Kasper played
such a great game before I mean it's
such a feature that he lost this
position probably it was not successful
in terms of result but actually they
played really interesting games
especially Gary I mean he deserved
actually to to win this game he was
dominating most of the game I want to
say the last 15 20 moves is where he
spoiled it with no time on his clock is
there we see uh one of the chasing rules
alireza just staring at the at the sheet
that shows the position now how do you
take it from move one and try to analyze
this in your head again I break it down
how do you what are the stages right I
break it down from what I'm trying to
achieve and you you said it very well
yourself so let's say after E2 E4 and I
visualize my development but then I do
it the opposite and say uh let's say I'm
playing a berserk attacker yes somebody
is going to do something like really
really crazy it's not in my style so if
I play a move like E4 can my opponent go
berserk and you know do something crazy
like like sacrificing gambiting upon
two or three pawns I don't even care you
know to try to take advantage but you
said Anastasia where's my Pawn
weaknesses what would I attack like if
the pawn on B2 was let's say there was a
knight on C1
I'd start thinking about how could I
attack this Pawn on B2 so that's another
approach what what would you uh how
would you approach this position
Christian well basically the same way
you guys just mentioned I would be
thinking about and focusing on what are
my bad pieces once again in the position
I will be seeing the Knight on E1 I can
visualize a situation where I do play E4
and then D4 and that Knight goes behind
the pawn the d-pawn on D3 that's where I
feel like all my pieces are playing in a
very healthy manner so I can start with
both either D4 or E4 at the same time
this is why I don't like starting with
D4 because after D5 I don't get E4
anymore at least not as easy I have to
go maybe F3 and change completely change
my strategy in the position once again
the battle
revolves around controlling the center
who controls the center whoever controls
the center there actually and we've seen
this in the first couple of games has
the much easier play we've seen that
even in the game between Gary and
Nakamura from last round Gary was on top
from the beginning he was controlling
the center he was putting pressure on
his opponent this is the key in this
chess 960
situations you have to control the
center and go back to basics go back to
what you were taught as a kid control
the center this is it so there's they
cannot rely on any sort of theoretical
knowledge so they have to go back to the
basics right yes also I'm checking the
castling always like yeah where am I
gonna put my king one of the reasons why
I would be attracted to the opening move
t2d4
is always I'm I'm thinking where is the
king and land or end up the king is on
B8 and it seems to me the natural Square
for the bishop would be F4 very smart
right so D2 d to D4 Bishop F4
E2 E3 and I want to let me just make
some moves on the board for a second
d45 Bishop F4 this is what I'm saying
you put a knight I don't know I'm just
going to put the Knight here
um E2 E3 and I'm going to do a bad move
and I want to open up this queen as well
right so this would be I mean this is a
very very Cooperative opponent right
this is what I I start thinking that the
bishop will get out of the way by the
way I think I'm going to Castle
queenside somehow if I get all in all of
those moves Anastasia what would be
would your approach be like Christians
with E4 yeah I think D4 and Bishop
before I like it and also I'm thinking
about the castling as I told you so if
the Mish remove the bishop to F4 then we
can do the castling right I mean and
Bishop from D1 should also move right
exactly so then we can um
let's just make something sooner we
developed the Bishops
chances to do the costlings
unfortunately for me this reminds me too
much of the London and I can't say I'm a
big fan of the London yes so we would
get some symmetry here almost quite
normal yet but it's getting closer and I
think Christian's right there's it's
it's almost impossible for me to imagine
a scenario where the Knight on G1
doesn't jump to F3 but now I have to
start to think could I possibly be oh
crazy and start thinking you can do
whatever you want it's fish or random
you know and I get to take my move back
right very important something doesn't
work out right which Basics is Yasser
and all these ideas yeah they look very
nice but there's a night coming to D6
and that stops everything in its tracks
okay but we tried it yes it looked nice
yeah it looks beautiful it looks
beautiful 96 is it shows that's the
first problem defense B7 and
blocks the power of the bishop in the
first two rounds
um Anastasia of the 10 players in the
event who has impressed you the most at
this moment handled their clock well
handled their positions
of course
he only has one and a half points I want
to inform you you know he's not exactly
leading the journalism what do you think
about nepo's play yeah he also actually
showed a really good Skill Center still
nerves I mean especially in the game
with Levon I think he was definitely in
trouble but he managed to find really
great moves and won this queen so he
showed really great creativity and this
is what it's all about future chess the
referendum they want your creativity to
shine
yes and for you Christian who well I
love that assessment that an associate
just made it's about the creativity of
Jan he's uh been getting bad positions
out of the opening actually in the first
game against Peter he was completely
losing from an objective point of view
at least he was I think my history
against the engines then in the second
round with the white pieces once again
he was worse out of the opening after
the first three four moves but then his
creative mind just took him over at the
Urgent started playing good moves
putting a lot of pressure on his
opponents found that idea with Queen F6
in the game between himself and Levon
that was the key idea Levon was just
picking up material on the queen side
and hoping that nothing is happening on
the king side not so fast Queen to F6
came and that was a big big problem for
levon's King so definitely a creative
mind I have to say I'm impressed with
the way nepo is carrying himself in this
tournament very good alireza in a
rematch against shaqreer shackriar had a
great position in the singfield cup
Bishop takes F2 check probably at this
moment I think most of us have thought
the game was over that Shaq was going to
win it seven moves later it was Shaq who
was resigning one of the most stunning
turnarounds we've seen at the top uh
and also by the way I don't yes yes of
course varusian did choose Hikaru but
he's struggling oh yes but he was Lucky
by the way now
to win against yes I'm sure that this
moment he was like oh yeah well but this
is how Hikaru bounces back he's
incredibly tenacious resourceful and he
plays very very fast puts puts you under
pressure you feel that ticking clock and
Gary felt the the clock
and let's not forget what happened to
Hikaru in the blitz section of the Saint
Louis rapid and Bliss just a couple of
weeks ago he completely demolished his
opposition once this guy gets going it's
very difficult to stop him so you better
not let him get in the groove right you
you mean he demolished his opposition
and Bliss
and he did very poorly well in the rapid
he was it almost felt like he was just
warming up and in day three he actually
did quite well in the rapid as well and
that allowed him to have some chances
going into the blitz Portion by the way
the king's Gambit is very popular both
in the farugia game as well as hikaru's
game let's see what other games we've
got do you know that Yani polishing made
the course on to Sable about King's
Gambit so what the shame to play case
Gambit against him you know even in the
fisherendo and in the king's Gambit uh
well uh Wilhelm Steiner it's the very
first world chess champion said uh the
best way to refute her Gambit is first
to accept it so what we see in you raise
a game shakery art took the pawn on F4
and said are you going to recapture with
the queen and Perugia said no I'd rather
recapture with the bishop uh too late
it's four too late wow okay Knight F6
not
not even F6 but Knight F6
uh intending there is uh
a problem
uh this is getting a little interesting
and what do you have for us Christian
actually my boards are not up oh so so
we've got completely I'm looking at your
board right now yes we've got total
Mastery of the situation that's great I
did see a game uh being played I don't
have the position right now so I'm not
100 sure I will be able to Showcase that
but after Queen 2 F4 Knight to E7 D4
yes Knight to G6 yes
Queen to F2 and this was a game between
some top players on literacy in the
leeches database around 2400. so
definitely this position might have been
explored in the past quite an
interesting one position two seven nine
two seven nine yes out of the possible
960. really close to one
and uh what what do we have instead uh
just a second after Knight E7 for some
strange reason I'm not quite sure why E2
and E7 are the squares
yeah exactly not sure
I mean it Knight F6 very uh correctly
prepping uh Bishop G4 that was stopped
by h2h3 I don't know but for me I feel
like black is doing really well here but
white maybe is threatening to play C4
it's for example G4 and driving in the
night away because of the strange
position of this queen uh I was thinking
that I might try just to develop Bishop
to D7
I don't know if you do play as you say
Anastasia yeah I don't have time yes I
don't know I mean almost hanging
true yes so probably I don't have time
to play D4 and D5 so exactly take care
of this phone yeah exactly okay it
doesn't work so well
but he did play Queen D6 oops excuse me
a knight of A3 Queen not not Bishop t7
apologies Queen D6
okay Bishop E7 Bishop E6
castles I always like when the king's on
V8 and you go all the way across the
board yeah a queen D6
and from White's point of view he would
probably like to play D4
Knight D3 C4 like you said and the
bishop will come out
to ah you're you're you're back with us
uh I'm back and I'm seeing the game
between firuja and mahmet exploding okay
that one is a brilliant one now let's
take a look at what happened uh it seems
like all of these players are at least a
large portion of them are playing this
idea with E4 E5 and then F4 right e45 F4
or Knight Wii to Preparing the move F4
this seems to have been at least one of
the positions analyzed and one of the
ideas analyzed uh during the break and
after taking on F4 of alireza came with
this idea of sacrificing the pawn with
the move d4 allowing the move G5 playing
it exactly like a king's Gambit G5 H4
Knight to F6 targeting the pawn on e4
immediately and I really like what shock
is doing he is opening up the Avenue for
his species and he's doing that with
Tempo while Ali Reza on the other hand
is just like uh swarming around with his
Queen but definitely it doesn't seem
like he's doing the right things my
position is very very safe on this side
you're going to take on G5 I'm going to
take back and that's actually going to
allow me to introduce my queen into play
via the H file so you have to be careful
with white about those type of
Tendencies opening up the age file you
might have some problems on the king
side you're not going to Castle on the
king side so you have to remove all of
these pieces this responsive one as well
as the bishop on D1 before you can
Castle alongside with the rule coming to
D1 in the meantime what it seems like I
have to do is Target the queen on B3
let's go A5
A5 seems to be or the right approach in
this position and I have to say I'm
looking at the position and it's
starting to look quite unpleasant for
white if you have to go move such as A4
well I can go Rook to A6 once again the
goal Remains the Same I need to find a
way to get to your queen Rook 2 A6 is a
brilliant way to do that if you do go C4
that opens up the H7 B1 diagonal and
after Bishop F5 you might have some
problems with your king definitely
trending in Black's favor this game
between Ali resin chakriar thank you for
that uh Christian and you're right so
I'm saying E4 E5 almost exclusively and
then white is playing for F4 and or D4
Lavon is playing for D4 he's played in
fact but I was very curious as to what
Gary would do after E4 e592 that
Preparatory move that you spoke about
Christian either you want to uh defend
the D4 error four squares Gary said
that's five let's go let's go now for me
I that was a bit of a surprise seriously
I was expecting Knight H6 because I was
expecting that you would like to
recapture the night maybe the queen will
have another square but uh Gary said nah
nah nothing doing I want to capture with
the queen and uh Fabi has achieved this
position I think I'm up to date with the
players yes I am after this so different
approaches across the board uh almost
both nights are actually in play right
now
and this was the initial problem that we
had with the white pieces right finding
uh
both nights into the game and this is
exactly what uh Fabiano managed to
accomplish yeah his problem pieces I
like what he's doing yes and also his
other problem piece is this bishop on D1
this guy won't have any problems finding
uh an active square but you're right the
knights are out and what was the other
game where the knights were out was it
uh the fruit no not that game there is a
Dominguez game yeah which Peter does
have both of his nights out exactly
and linear yes this was the different I
don't know that I'm not a fan of these
92-97 moves but okay uh live on an Apple
with a very intriguing exchange
sacrifice right now oh
that's dang let's go back okay this is
where we left it
uh D5 H6 H3 sorry this is where we left
it Queen D6 D4
I thought he was doing all of this to
get early uh kingside castling and he
tricked us
he wanted to control the E4 squared
95. give me that oh so he just gave this
exchange like that
well that was he was being pretty
flippant there what's going on uh
Christian that is we're taught as kids I
like it you like it I like it why from a
practical perspective from an objective
point of view maybe white given the fact
that he's an exchange up and if you do
have an engine by your side then I'm not
able to use that then you're probably
going to defend this but from a
practical perspective you see this
Knight swarming around your king you
would love instinctively to play the
move Knight to F or start exchanging
pieces well Knight to C3 is coming and I
think you can resign on this path if you
do that you cannot do that so how do you
get out
maybe you play the move C3
but it's counterintuitive because it
opens up the H7 P1 diagonal Bishop F5 is
coming on the board I understand you do
have a protector that Bishop coming to
C2 so Hikaru needs to stop thing
understand this type of nuances in the
position but still from a practical
perspective I have to say I'm enjoying
Black's position
no it's nice sexual sacrifice and it it
seems like it's working from time to
time also showed today that it worked
really well in his first game one of the
things that I I I stressed time and time
again is in the rapid and Blitz most
especially the birds the faster the time
control the more obvious it is that
having the initiative is actually a
really important Dynamic
um because when you have the initiative
the defender starts to see ghosts and he
starts to say how do I neutralize how do
I stop your threats how do I trade off
pieces it's like they're on the back
foot they're not thinking about how am I
going to kill this guy they're thinking
how am I going to survive the next 10
moves and so there's a lot of options to
go wrong in the position for example if
you play the move C4 very obvious and
good looking movies intuitive right yeah
you're making space for the bishop to go
to the C2 you're kicking the pieces back
well Bishop to F6
check that out and if you take on D5
Knight to D2 Chuck
hello hello you cannot take because
Queen takes B2 is coming nice
I have a lot of problems potentially in
the position for the white king
I you know the moment you mentioned C2C
you the moment you mentioned that night
after the desirable Knight F4 is met by
Knight C3 I liked the suggestion of C3 a
lot it's it's because you know I can
cover up with Bishop C2 and then I start
to think that okay I'll get my Rook to
D1 and I can untangle my pieces with a
future Bishop F4 idea so that's very
nice I just wanted to turn our attention
uh to the the game of uh
Shaq because guess what that
I I see it
I say a mess
I see a mess on my board but I do see
the move A5 and Rook A6 something what
we discussed right well Christian was
recommending and before I thought about
it I'll erase it is like okay check it
out as far as I can tell they're playing
Fisher random but white farrugia has
developed exactly one piece
what can you tell us about Grand Master
chess
yeah you're supposed to develop your
pieces
only one piece but this is modern chess
develop only one piece ah but look at
this Knight D6 finally Bishop finally a
threat uh we can get get behind wow
um
Anastasia explained this to him
[Laughter]
really try to get it I don't know maybe
if white survived for some time it's not
going to be over so quickly if he
manages to bring his Knight on the five
night on this week uh somehow you know
if it's not lost immediately then maybe
you can that's that that's the trick
could it be is it lost immediately is
there I mean it feels like uh it's not
lost immediately Black's not good it's a
knight to F5 so of course C5 is a threat
right C5 wins that sure yeah sure get
out of uh Dodge right go Knight to F5
take advantage once again and focus on
the weaknesses in your opponent's
position
so if I try to defend then I'm walking
into a G4 that might be problematic and
well I'm sacrificing a piece actually I
don't I'm not moving the night my skin
is gone but you would yeah this is the
way to go right you've got to start
sacrificing the Knight F5 looks wrong
I'm not even convinced I'm going to take
that maybe I can even go Knight to G3
after Knight two three so I have ideas
of just simply continuing bouncing
around as well and Knight F5 is on the
board good move by shock we are really
good move and again this this bishop F5
is lurking oh yeah I'm not sure
I I'm pretty sure I don't want to lose
the light Square Bishop because
but now without the Knight on D6 I also
have the queen coming in yes you do uh
so Knight F5
that's really really challenging
unpleasant yes yes okay guys I really
want to show it now please yes nice uh
little three variation in that variation
after Queen to B4 I spotted it I don't
know if it works but right yes so I
think you can just like go to the same
variation
now I have to block right let's go Queen
A2 King A2 Queen before Queen right okay
but I'm losing everything right yes but
now after B3 what B3 so Queen takes C4
B3 yes I think I can go Queen takes
a
foreign
let's explain to Christian what he's
missed in these types of positions
Christian is a really good idea to take
the bishop
they do the same mistake okay
but this was your Genius
yes
Bishop B1 is what I call a 50 50. the
intentions there's only two moves for
white 50 50 shot but uh in any case that
is a winning line for Shaq and it's
because of that line that Knight F5 has
got an Ali raise a big trouble
stopped he's Frozen actually let me
remind you that Trump already played
this Rook just remove you remember
thinking that it's check was uh jeffig's
song he played this Rook just remove and
he just took his piece on G5 is this
simple thought that it's check so
anything can happen actually
no we we were joking even with Shaq that
uh you know he tried two illegal moves
yes the one in one game
and we said you know we admire your
persistence consistency
he couldn't play for a couple of games
after that he said like I can lose the
game but not to do it in one game it's
not possible exactly
um this move Knight F5 it's got me
thinking that maybe it's time to get rid
of this Rook so that Knight g3 at least
I'm not sure it doesn't come with the
tempo can I take on D4
it's legal absolutely it's illegal
um okay uh help help us no no no no no
no no no this is the bishop F5 variation
that I'm worried about so I have to go
Queen D1 Queen C3 I thought about it
maybe some but then okay
I think that the queen defends the Rooks
yes
okay Queen D1 let's go yes Queen D1 but
in the worst case I can just go Bishop
five Chuck and that's what aren't you
helping me over then I can take on G5
I'm still going to be a pawn up at the
end just uh just yes materialistic so
much very materialistic not only that
but the problem is your pieces are not
going out anytime soon you Castle it
doesn't help you your king is still
extremely unsafe agreed so by the way a
Black's King on the other hand really
looks uh
comfy with both pawns A4 and C4 like
that there's so many holes on the light
squares around your king it's not
looking good right now for a while and
Anastasia the times because again that
little green box is like it's a
challenge
no they give us a nice perspective it's
almost 10 minutes similar yes like 10 10
minutes 13 years no but it's clear that
alireza is a little bit thinking longer
yeah yeah he's on the back foot trying
to figure out what to do in this
position it's not so easy I want to jump
around because actually it's kind of
funny in the game between Fabi and Gary
there's a Black Knight on F5 in that
game as well uh but fobby is actually no
he's not nursing an extra Pawn there's a
Pawn on D6 let's see it when we left
kind of Echoes you you see this H7 H6
move we another game we saw h2h3 we oh
that that's the move let's do that
slowly let's appreciate it looks too
much like a game of chess
come on this is too much looking like a
game of chess ah well already it's not
quite there yet but one one Castle yeah
that's it quick quick question do you
prefer white position or Black's
position here I think I think why why no
black has got I just feel like I'm a
little bit ahead in terms of development
you still have a circular castle Yeah
your Rooks are connected you are in once
you do the long Castle maybe I will be
thinking about taking on F5 or opening
up that diagonal and then focusing on A7
so I still feel you're a few moves away
from safety as black but aren't you are
you or are you not concerned about
Knight takes E3 and giving up your dark
Square oh this was just my first
instinct I'm not saying that
black is not doing well in the position
but I would prefer playing with the
white pieces okay A2 A4 again across the
board you see The Echoes of uh the
players playing uh similar maybe they
check each other
for ideas right guys
because let's jump no more is down to
his last five minutes no way really his
opponent with 15 minutes and whoa that's
what I was talking about the
practicality of this position
it's not looking good right now I don't
think you're in time anymore to defend
everything as white
you missed a bit you did not play the
move C3 followed by Bishop to C2 you
started with Rook to F1 and now after F5
a really crafty move if you go C3 well
I'll go Rook to A6 yeah and then you
have to once again start thinking about
so many problems coupled with the idea
of Rook to F6 but also Rook to B6 and
then Knight takes C3 yep this move A5 by
Nepal was such a good move and we do
have Queen D3 on the board okay kind of
stuff okay six came immediately what
came immediately okay okay we did
sidestep Rook F6 thread Anastasia but
yes but you play with your queen so many
moves it doesn't look good right and
some a moment ago there was some line
with Bishop F6 and Knight D2 well I can
see Bishop F6 and Rook B6 and I would
get very very excited uh having the
black pieces here uh definitely Hikaru
on the back foot and what a start for
Jan as his uh won his first two games
alireza again
Knight F3
G4 Bishop D3
and Rook G1 and it's the peace sacrifice
we spoke about but I think that was
actually uh practically uh the best
thing that he could do I mean yes I
understand uh I'm material down but I'm
fighting in this position uh the other
position I was getting killed yes
at least he has some Center three bones
maybe hoping to finish his development
and right yeah I mean you know I'll I'll
try to make such moves I'm not
enthusiastic don't get me wrong I like
the extra piece but uh Shaq will have to
work let me see what about Peter's
Fiddler
lastly this seems to be the most
calm this is almost looking like a chess
game I think Peter really perhaps needs
to make a draw yes I don't know it's
just to get out the first day with just
to get on the scoreboard
uh what what's going on between Lavon
and
um
whoa whoa whoa
A5 again we're seeing these ideas of A45
ah sorry I was thinking isn't he just
leaving the night on E7 on pre yes he is
but there was also Queen takes D4 yeah
so okay this is a really nice move
because now I'm threatening Bishop E3
exactly seven no matter what you do
yes even if you go down and take this
exactly yeah
so just uh just to put some moves on the
board uh what we're talking about is
you've got your choice do you want to
allow Nate Knight take C6 mate or do you
want to lose your queen oops I think
linear is in deep trouble right now Rook
E4 that's an eve easy move to miss yes
Rook E4 wow
um
how do you define it I'm not happy I'm
not happy Knight C7
to uh
to D5 to defend the Knight and so let's
say I go C4 now okay let's write the
most aggressive way
so aggressive yeah not only seven night
on E7 oops that was not I wasn't I was
thinking about Queen takes G2 as well as
Bishop F5
that's okay I will just go right Bishop
to C2 and defend uh agreed uh no
question about it
this is
c2c4 and it this looks looks like
another one of those pea sacrifices that
I'm having to make
and I'm not happy at making them um did
you see a better alternative I
let's jump to the Yarns game because
again he wow uh Hikaru is getting killed
uh that's it that is no
C4 well as my trainer would say Hikaru
is going to die with a full tummy I mean
he took a bishop he took a pawn
this looks like mate is coming uh I
think Knight D2 or 92 well first of all
what are we going to do about our Queen
let's say we hide it let's say we just
hide
now we have to explain to Christian that
the rules of Chess
try to redeem myself no no no but you
and Shaq I can feel it I mean instant
attraction uh hold on uh what What's the
killer killer guys this is a Checkmate
in a few moves yes
yes you cannot really protect sweet and
if I take it the other way it doesn't
matter because I still have Queen C2
coming
uh I was trying to make it happen
differently
no no no no no
which means get back with the Queen's
wage for well but then that allows
Bishop to F5 that's your Bishop to F5
move and
differences between the two players
speaks volumes right yes I think it's
not a good sign for Hikaru that he spent
so much time already in both of the last
games well the inclusion I mean of C4
and queen takes d8 that was just really
really asking for trouble and you could
see that Hikaru is not a happy camper
here he's taken the bishop he's shaking
his head it's like oh yeah he's not
happy at all 92 check threats as
Christian mentioned Rook takes D1 as
well hold on what was the what was the
cleanest there's a lot of ways I think
even uh just simply Knight D2 and then
which by five but [ __ ] by five how do
you defend absolutely threat of night D2
or Knight C3 double Checkmate guys have
you ever have you ever in your career
had
double A Checkmate
fives no three what did he do queen
takes D6 Queen takes D6 well there was
no real choice because we were just
seeing Rook takes D1 mate no and he
knows it I mean
the queen is coming to D3
yes by absolutely for sure there's just
no way he doesn't win this game Queen
takes D6 B3 1990 and I can just see from
the from the rocking of his head and
hikara is just like
get me out of here
just understand it
you can see a slight uh smile I always
love his face yeah that fine well
deserved well deserve what a day for him
seriously yes nice to sacrifice actually
it's really great sacrifice and you were
right to Christians saying that it was
really practical great chance
for nipples again the only way out was
for him to go that move C3 which was not
easy not easy uh four games remaining
guys let's just jump to the game between
Fabi and Gary
not too much excitement going on it
feels like it's rather evenish I think
the alireza one is very exciting let's
jump to alireza
wow still a completely chaotic Affair
going on over here as we left it
um
alireza made a very good practical
decision to sacrifice a piece
to try to take over the initiative a
moment ago there was a rook on B6
attacking guess what the roles reversed
absolutely now it's a rook on V3 and
tonight E3 Bishop takes
yeah this is this is the whatever
happens from here happens but this is
the best that alireza could have hoped
for a moment ago this queen was coming
to before no longer sorry amanstasia no
I just started see some you know like
like Knight C6 Queen A6 Rook V8 I mean
all this immediately all these ideas are
jumping share share yes like I don't
know if it was white to play here maybe
Knight C6 is the threat exactly this is
what uh yes
to see all these ideas on your
fingertips I get it I get it so uh wait
a minute have the roles reversed is the
magic back oh absolutely is in the game
I mean he's the one attacking right now
yeah only a couple of moves ago he was
the one being under attack on the B file
that Rook on B6 was creating a lot of
tension now is the work on B3 that's
creating a lot of tension and I think
there's maybe just one way to defend
this one you have to solidify that
square C6 Knight C6 the move that you
mentioned Anastasia coupled with Queen
A6 is a big threat right so you have to
reinforce that defense with the move
Queen to E8 not easy already again
you've been on the attack the whole game
and now you have to defend passively not
easy I have to say from a practical
perspective it is Ali Reza who is having
all the fun right now well indeed but I
I agree that Queen E8 is a necessary
defensive move and to me it's appealing
simply because the queen hasn't moved
and it was
is not doing anything on the f8 Square
so Queen E8 looks practical what are the
times now
oh sorry what are the times of the
players ah yes so let's check the time
because it reversed it was nine to 13.
it's almost the same actually so it's
not so bad I mean well isn't both
players yes five it's six so almost and
now it's yeah it's the same time and
actually it means that
is doing well I mean even let's just
jump to Lavon for a quick second because
Lanier has errored egregiously he's in
deep trouble now whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa we can see this incredibly powerful
Bishop as well as the Rook I can see
this other bishop and maybe on a good
day you could just play Rook to D7 as
well yes uh clock times on this one
times let's check it carefully yes what
about timing
yes we have 10 minutes against one okay
linear yes only one minute yes it's not
really a surprise I know he likes to
think about it
but look at this position oh it's
terrible
okay during a strange voice we do have
not ours our leader in the uh studio uh
with the perfect perfect start yes
absolutely Christian uh you came into
the studio and you uttered the words
development is key interest 960. yeah
take us through that
uh that's it that's it so are you
looking at chess 960 given the fact that
you don't rely on Theory as much as just
going back to the basics basically
I'd say that it's quite fun like to
analyze the starting position with uh
you know the guys around and uh you know
to come up with somebody you know some
opening concept
and that's probably what we never had a
chance to do because we we are born like
now not like 200 years ago
uh in normal chess but uh yeah I mean
the analyzing is quite fun and playing
is also fun especially if you like if
you're in some games like today but uh
as from UK like this okay 15 minutes
before we round is like something I
would I would say my favorite how do you
analyze the position that you are given
for only like 15 minutes do you try to
go narrow deep with your analysis how
did you guys approach it no we just you
know
we just check if E4 works yeah and then
we calculate it yeah I mean the case I'm
you know shuffle pistols around it
definitely felt like development was key
in this last game against Hikaru take us
through the game a little bit uh okay so
first of all he dared to play king's
damaging yes but I told you
yeah and yeah actually we together with
Shakira maybe he's not I mean he got
like a winning position out of the
opening I think but then he did
something wrong so we came up with this
idea takes in 97. so preparing both E5
and D5 and F5 I mean like normal
developing move so after 92 D5
uh takes
yeah somehow I'm not sure I think black
should be fine here because okay all
this development and somehow you don't
really want to play C4 here is why but
because the king is only one uh but
maybe you should uh and like but yeah
still you don't want to weaken your king
So Queen F3 was something
out of six all right developing move H3
and here I just decided I don't know to
to put all the pieces in the center I'm
not sure if it's good we'll get back to
this game in just a second let's take a
look at firuja because things are
heating up if I had put it on your board
and we'll get uh we'll get the comments
of uh nebro as well uh Shaq Shaq spoiled
uh a very promising looking attack he's
got a piece but as you've been showing
the initiative is so important nepo a
big Advantage for white you would say
but I I can't even see the position
maybe okay maybe maybe the the big
position there you go
okay but still kick has an extra piece
and he's not getting mated yeah so
that's some good news for him
I mean uh Bishop F3 E2
okay E2 okay probably
I hit D6 is my suggestion yeah like six
but who knows what will happen yeah so
maybe like an extra Queen is even not
enough to win this position so so I
don't know like G2 whichever
okay let's see what happens okay so
probably two is uh not as good when we
like D6 was chilling here okay the six
is very topical
um it's not as good like if you see it
like here but
you know other words is like always
you know what's going on you have no
idea what are you facing let's take a
look at what's up C7 takes D6 has
happened go ahead put it on your board
uh the D7 is the problem actually C7
takes D6 well
that's huge and I guess if you take them
probably Queen A6 just finishes the game
yeah okay YouTube Pawn unfortunately
it's too slow here
otherwise I should find it right Bishop
takes B7 is well we should be seven but
DJ C5 is it like it's like that clear
so you win a queen but uh I have what
one two three pieces probably as you
might get and you know like the bishop
is the best defender of a king so like I
have two Bishops defending my king
yeah I mean
if it would be like a Time scramble it
uh this is still another one ah it could
it could end like in any of three
results but
I'd say like some D5 I would I would
probably play D5 here with D5 blunders
like Knight takes D5 and in the position
we
uh we have similar stuff to exchange
like it's very nice but Knight D5 and
then we'll get one suddenly comes here
Queen X5 if one can get two
the game goes on you still have to worry
about checkmates yeah that's quite
annoying first
yeah Rook to D3 there's still a lot of
threats for uh yeah I mean okay it's
like it's completely I mean incredible
position so you
know I have no idea I frankly have no
idea what's happening but none of them
will happen actually because
never mind they take C5 this is the
position we currently have on the board
so we might actually go into that oh
this actual one well we have Bishop
takes B7 guys and he takes C5 on the
board
dang wow wow that's huge oh
but you do have to become materialistic
and not look at Checkmate ideas after C6
Queen to A6 right now go for the Queen
Bishop takes C6 has to be played no C6
maybe just how do we how do I play after
C6 by the way
probably also King crunch to C7 yeah so
like I just
stick to the you know on this Minefield
yeah I stick to the dark squares and
that's how I like that's how I escape
well you do have uh two extra pieces so
that helps when you're not when you are
mated it might you know be not enough I
mean even even three actors okay this is
like
probably Chuck is now dreaming to make
you know this short fancy short Castle
here at some point like teleport is King
too whatever like to G8 here okay just
don't touch me so Bishop C6 is on the
board
King C7 probably is forced right yes he
played it otherwise it's
there goes
Black's going to end up with three
pieces for the queen but still his king
is not okay well yeah well he's defended
D5 honestly I like that move I like that
move
yeah right
yes let's move
oh my goodness
well Queen B5 is very nice you're like
stretching some Queen A5 Queen B8 Rook
B7 first I can change Chase the king
until
until the resignation yeah probably
and The Rook is hanging
it seems to me that you like these kind
of chaotic positions uh uh very much in
your game do you by the way I think it
was played D5 you should have to take I
mean of course I like a tough turkey two
years of playing petrol
anyone would like it
we we let you out of the prison you know
you probably have to consider or maybe
like King D7 King D7 but I'm afraid this
is like a bit too slow
I think the seven is quite a move I
think yeah so that's three ten feet oh
okay anything to be recommended
[Music]
C6 Bishop A6 oh after can you do
something yeah
okay I don't care about anything but
then I go Queen C5
but you even have C5 uh
sorry yeah okay wow
nope it's time to get on the running
shoes
probably probably only one wow Rook F1
check
and again the the clock times of the
players if you don't mind one minute 43
seconds against two minutes for Shaq
you know probably okay all this computer
is moves but
Lisa looks like all these moves are so
easy because it's like I think like it's
exactly like his cup of Cherokee such
positions
what the heck that stopped Queen D6
yes sir that's about because of
developing yeah yeah it wasn't developed
you know but the bishop on d8 and the
bishop on C8 have not moved but it's
like you know it's like Dean Duran won
the game against Fabio against Rapport I
think with his Bishop on C8 and never
never moved uh within like 60 moves or
something yes exactly so he's like we we
made a cheer in studio when he finally
moved his Bishop it's like he remembered
okay so how do you continue this
position and try to give some sort of a
check but okay check uh I mean check is
only a check here so no one ever died
from a check as they say that's at least
why because if I take on G1 and they
have rookie one second and E1 also yeah
so let's go for that yeah sir let's go
Queen A8 what do you do queen you got a
queen all right
all right you want Queen right
okay also like uh maybe you notice it on
the camera like uh he got his Queen yeah
he's moving his you know future Queen
closer to to him yeah like to make sure
it it won't run anyway
cc6
where are we looking at E6 I have no
idea okay
well this is the idea yeah
it's not even a check okay come on
promote
B7 review
yes
that would be amazing the king will be
running
it's a nice prophylactical move
foreign
because you take a form for the second
time maybe that's the idea behind
uh but it's always better to have a
queen
and don't have one
I guess great
okay it's not an option because Queen
takes C5 here like ends the game
immediately
okay that's a good point crucial moment
here and clocks again
I think yeah it's a few seconds black
has an extra piece yeah in the very end
we're looking on C6
no I mean okay you want queens uh rugby
seven Bishop B7 Queen D7 King B6 screen
B7 King C5 Queen DB5 King B6 Rook F1
Queen B4 Rook D1 King D7 Rook D7 uh
King E8 C7
Bishop C7 and another one yeah Rook C7
uh Rook B5 heavy okay rook and game Draw
that's good
congratulations yeah
a big day for you do you feel like your
experience from 2019 from the World
Championship uh matches is giving you an
edge in this tournament I don't think
like we can seriously speak about
experience in official random chassis
uh it's basically pretty much just like
in some rapid chess in other rapid chess
it's uh based on you know your
you know how is it going generally yes
so it is going great your games are also
you know going great and vice versa so
I'd say uh
speaking of the king's Gambit yeah I
mean it was like quite a new opening for
me when I came I was making all these
courses uh and uh and lasted quite quite
a while
and somehow I changed it
for you know for myself uh the
revelation of the material yeah so let's
say okay you play okay this Catalan you
play king's Gambit you get some other
lines and the pawn is not as long you
know it's not as important as it seems
here so like
when you play for squares for the center
and so on probably we all know this in
the childhood uh but we never okay we
quite
you know we are not using this concept
too often yeah but it's always helpful
to play when you're feeling happy yeah
so yeah congratulations we'll see you in
the next couple of days thank you but I
also wanted to show you online oh
suddenly from my game because I just
wanted to check it if it like if it
exists or not we have to catch the end
of this game but yes we can definitely
keep you here in the studio okay then
we'll look at the game game it looks
like a pawn breakthrough uh who's
winning this one it seems like black
five
they see faster so you go C4
probably
[Music]
um
Peter resigned top three for Peter
and uh please quickly uh nepo show us
the the the line and yeah he's curious
so let's say in this position he could
play instead of rookie one he could play
C3 move like 12. yes that was the key
move C3 I was expecting and after C3 uh
I was creating something like you know
um okay night
okay let's see Knight F2 Knight F2 yeah
Queen F2
Bishop F5 Bishop C2 takes okay I
understand this is a Cooperative
variation but Queen E4 yes Queenie for
check King D1 Bishop H4
uh Queen F3 and castles
yeah and if you take only four then I go
with Knight E3 mate yeah but okay that
could be winning if not 94 I didn't see
94.
very excited okay wow like if I'm really
winning there is a bit I didn't really
trust myself but I felt like wow it's if
it happens it would be quite nice but
yeah that's nice truth truth yours yeah
it never wins
yarn congratulations thank you we'll uh
see you in the next thank you thank you
congratulations absolutely we do have a
result Gary Kasparov resigned and also
we have another result uh starting with
the answer unbelievable it's a draw
crazy game that we've witnessed I mean
uh Rook F1 rookie six Queen this is what
Dion said I think yeah creation yes this
was Jan's variation
and he said something like uh oh my gosh
it's a draw yes oh that's crazy and Gary
Kasparov when we left it it was kind of
even Anastasia where did it go wrong for
Gary
he lost a pawn
and then he won it back
but he
lost a piece wait a minute it's a double
attack what has he done
attack
that's it oh he just pondered us maybe
he thought Knight D3 or something but
and we have in studio with Christian
Lavon aronium
Lavon first of all uh congratulations to
all the three that's a pretty decent
result of Victory against the legend
himself Gary Kasparov did that fuel at
the beginning of the tournament for you
no actually because I wasn't really
playing well in that game I I have I had
an amazing position out of the opening
and then I think I started just thinking
every move is good so and then Gary
played very well he defended he maybe
even got some chances to have an
advantage and I think he plundered at
that moment for uh nepo he was saying
that he's really enjoying those uh 10
minutes before the round analyzing with
his peers do you feel the same way and
how do you feel about your team let's
see all right I mean it's amazing this
is like a dream come true for NHS player
I mean I understand that this is a you
know chess players chess I would say I
understand maybe for public it's
difficult to follow Fisher random but
the amount of joy we get playing this I
don't know if anything can be compared
because well there isn't for it
we make mistakes on first couple of
moves it shows that the game is actually
eternal
I mean there is no solving to this game
and it also shows that you know we have
a lot to learn about Chess because you
know when you blunder and move two or
you make a mistake and move one it means
uh you know this is a really an amazing
game you know because after all I mean I
personally spent 30 years studying chess
and still you know in this game I make
mistakes early on so it's it's a
wonderful feeling and also for us as
commentators I'm sure also for the fans
out there seeing ideas that similar to
what Nepal was showing with like long
castle and then Knight E3 Checkmate that
move 20 is just incredible Now take us
through this last game against uh
Dominguez yes so we analyzed this with
Fabi because Fab is my partner
internalize and well he's a good friend
of mine so we thought E4 e592 makes the
most sense and here we thought F5 has to
be played
uh with the idea why was that
yeah we thought uh if black you know uh
allows white you know if he goes Knight
F6 for example instead of F5 then a
white has F4 we thought this this can be
very unpleasant and you know everything
is connected with the not nice position
on E8 yep because you really want to
bring out that knight from E8 and
which side gets you know to block that
Knight with the pawn on E5 gets the
advantage with the pawn only five or the
pawn on yeah or E4 so that's why you
wanted to play F5 as black in this
position yeah we thought this is kind of
interesting is this a move at this point
uh yeah as far as it's quite a possible
move we thought maybe this will be 97
you know maybe maybe two
water down very soon so we're thinking
something like F5 EF
and the
yeah we thought this this might be
slightly better I saw you very often not
necessarily liking taking the queen out
with queen of five but rather choosing
yeah but 96 D4 is the issue I think
if you take on F5 uh take only five and
if you take here Bishop takes H6 or no
94 I thought simply take take you know
and then just play
yeah hit 4G for anything I think it
looks good the rule comes into the game
quickly the reason because you have more
developed feces is that correct uh I
think it's just no the real reason why
white is better here is that both bishop
and Knight are a d8 and E8 have the
ideal position on F6 okay and both of
them cannot
occupy that position right so one of the
pieces is going to be stuck because if
black tries to put the bishop on F6
phone on D5 and Knight on D6 you always
have this bishop F4 and the Knight is
kind of loose so that's the reason why
this is unpleasant for black makes sense
and he played move Knight to E7 yes uh
by the way he was also spending a lot of
time at this point yeah I think they
didn't really analyze 92. they didn't
look at 92. because if we don't play
Knight E2 I think uh black black has a
comfortable position yeah 97 he played
D4 this is six yeah the the thing I
thought he was going to do is to play
after Knight F3 Knight C6
yes I thought this was interesting
because I was thinking about D5 97 92 F5
F3
some kind of King's Indian I get to play
C4 and maybe it's a good same-ish for
white because I managed to kind of keep
the center intact
but after all he has the C6 A5 he should
be six it's awesome
also like that yeah just get some sort
of an end game like this yeah slightly
better for white but not a big deal
yeah and uh F5 somehow I thought is not
a good move but maybe I was wrong so E
Yeah taking on E5 of course possible but
AF looks logical
and now E4 I thought Knight G5 should be
a pleasant position for white because
you know b596
we get this
anything after I will play F3 you know I
got rid of my E1 Knight the Bishops are
starting to have a nice life definitely
looks good okay
so he took On d42 and Here Yeah Queen B5
is extremely unpleasant I felt
for him well there's a checkmating
threat in the position you have to worry
about Knight C6 first uh he decided to
take the passive route with Knight to E7
but probably the only way Rook to E1
C6 oh actually and now I see what I
blundered he had C5 here oh it's
embarrassing and if you take on E7
no you know what I blundered I forgot
that I cannot play Knight E6 it takes an
ic7
oh yeah this is so I had to play Queen
B3 first
oh yeah that's an embarrassing bunder of
course
so Queen to B3 in this position yeah in
order to have this now c596 and at least
you grab two Bishops have a better
position he did not see it either and
then it was a smooth sailing from here
yeah because
you didn't feel like he had any way out
anyway back into the game yeah yeah this
I think this rookie 4 is very precise
and it just finishes the game Levon
first of all congratulations on the two
victories what would you say is the
biggest factor of assessment in chess
960. whenever you see a new position
what are you looking for
Well normally you know uh if Bishops are
fancyed it gets much more boring because
you know you have to open the bishop but
in positions like this I think it's
quite exciting you you always look into
a possibility to get the center
and then you have to assess where your
positions are going to end up I mean
your pieces white pieces
and then of course where the king is
going to be so there's three factors are
extremely important because
quite often do you understand that G4
might be the best move in the position
in the start but then you're kind of you
know let's see what if what if I never
get the castle
all those risks so the reason why this
game is such a an amazing game another
reason yet another reason is that you
have Chances with black all the time
and unlike regular chests were with
black you're really suffering here you
you have a chance to take take over
because well as you see we make early
mistakes all of us definitely uh you're
enjoying these rounds this game it's a
pleasure to see you play and we'll see
you in the next couple of days thank you
thank you one quick question for you uh
Lavon I like to draw your attention to
this move 18 because I think this is a
magnificently unique moment to fish a
random chess you made that you normally
if you're going to Castle queenside the
King on E1 has to go through the D1
square but you're permitted to Castle
bringing the Rook attacking the queen
because you didn't go through the check
did you go to the Arbiter and ask him
hey hey
am I permitted to Castle you knew that
you could castle and it's a winning move
it wins on the spot yes you know for
example yes sir another example I will
tell you maybe it's a secret for you but
for example when your king is only one
yes Rook is on H1 and Black's Queen
let's say is on D5
you can Castle short but you cannot
Castle long yeah it's correct the H5 H1
square is not a problem but this is a
this is unique in the sense you're
castling and attacking the queen on the
same turn you don't have that in regular
chess you Castle short the there's a
queen on the f file the king can't go
through F1 but a very very nice Lavon uh
congratulations on your score we'll see
you tomorrow thank you very much
absolutely we'll learn another day every
day
from the best by the way yes we learn
from the best by the way our our
standings Anastasia after three rounds
who is leading now the tournaments with
three points he made 100 out of three
yeah is on the second place two and half
coins and then we have Lebo naronian and
the lyrics sharing the third place with
two points and we have a group of people
Wesley Social Security and linear
Dominguez was one and a half points
fifty percent in the tournament Hikaru
Nakamura has one point and unfortunately
Petersville there and very fast are on
the bottom absolutely absolutely and we
haven't uh Studio our second place uh
finisher of the day Fabiano with two and
a half points with Christians
three very intense but successful rounds
for you I would like to start with this
game between yourself and Mommy the
Earth because the position out of let's
say the opening it looked so funny it
looked like a Catalan but the bishop was
already on A2 there's a fiance cathode
Queen how did you feel about it yeah Jan
told me this was his idea to play C4 and
yeah it was it looked like a bad
position maybe I shouldn't take but
I didn't want to play passively
and
yeah what were you looking for in this
starting position what were your main
priorities I thought I need to Castle I
need to try to keep my C Pawn as long as
I can and if I can break with E5 or C5
at some moment that would be good
but usually E5 and C5 are met by def I
mean if I was usually met by D5 C5
rarely works but if it does then then it
can be quite good
um yeah again it's not on d8 once D5
comes and iron d8 gets very restricted
so I thought I'll play 97 Knight B6 and
Castle short and try to find a break
later on
when did you feel like you're oh yeah I
was very happy with C5 C5 at this point
because after B3 I thought it's very
messy and then I saw this move C5 it
took it wasn't my first intention first
I thought either CB or Bishop G4
followed by E5 some
CV Bishop B3 uh
thought
okay of course black is totally fine but
uh uh I thought white has compensation
because 94 Knight c53 are all kind of
streaming
um 94 next and yeah Bishop b694
something like this so I thought that
white would have compensation here on C5
I really
um was happy when I saw this move and
didn't see a clear follow-up for what
yeah and here I had to
you have an option of taking on D4 or
Knight to C6 how did you make this
decision Queen D4 Knight D4 I I just
looked like such a mess to me I I wasn't
sure I thought yeah of course this
should be good for black but uh too
messy I didn't want my queen to be in
the center and uh there should be three
yeah all sorts of ideas so
I think it's like 1960 I see C5 is the
move I didn't even consider this move
um
because actually I don't know why
because it's very logical and uh
yeah maybe we both didn't realize that
like an id4 Queen B7 usually this Pawn
is uh
it's defended an entire game from the
Knight on d8 and then suddenly
um it's hanging so I guess
Queen F3 then maybe you're thinking
about going Queen E3 or queen yeah I
think that he underestimated the danger
after D5
um
but I yeah this night before was very
important after that it's just because
Bishop B2 Bishop B5
that's his problem that uh
he's he's not getting the diagonal lion
and uh and if you think Bishop D4 is a
threat yeah just take Take Ah take I
uh okay I didn't realize Queen E3 was
possible here so yeah I would have to
find this bishop D4 to to Really
um
yeah Queen B7 and take take
and um the problem is Bishop on A2 is so
terrible my knight on B4 is a massive
piece and the other problem is 94 Queen
E5 that his Queen is dropped which is um
yeah so
so yeah he he underestimated I guess the
danger here and then it was
I thought pretty simple for the rest of
the game like I didn't think he had very
very many chances to to survive the end
game some chances but not too many and
then let's go to your final game against
the one Gary Casper it felt like the
position out of the opening was quite
balanced did you feel the same way yeah
I thought he was fine he found this nice
H6 G5 idea this was a
this was a I thought quite
quite an impressive maneuver this g59 G7
and then move the bishop and Castle
short
like I said I don't know there's a
castle shorter Castle long well he did
Castle short no but it's like it's at
this it's Castle short but it's it's a
very long Castle short so yeah here here
I realize I'm slightly worse
um but I didn't think it was a big deal
uh Bishop D3 you know I thought I'm more
or less control and then he played B6
very provocative
because he can just take and play for
example allow A5 in service no but it's
provocative because it allows Bishop C4
like I played um
then I thought that I
I started to take over
and then I completely lost control right
as I was taking over
like um yeah B4
yeah it works here it was bad
take
Knight B3 and now Knight F4 Knight C5
Queen F6 I thought I'm much better
but I didn't see the way and uh so I
tried to play it safe there's only one
way with Bishop to D7 and you're not
even that much better you know the thing
is Bishop D7 Works C5 Bishop F5 I was
considering this take take Queen C5
I mean like Queen of five uh Queen C5
Queen Chief I have Queen C3 and queen
okay yeah yeah I didn't see this okay
but I mean after Bishop takes yeah he's
also works I don't think he's uh not an
easy position by any means no no
even end games are are quite difficult
to prove an advantage yeah and then he
was suddenly better again I thought
um
like okay
yeah I played a very strange take in
rookie three I mean it's very stupid
you could take in Bishop G2 I don't know
what I was thinking it's just terrible I
mean
yeah quite I didn't even realize this
poem was hanging then suddenly I see
it's hanging and I'm like what am I
doing but you're very quickly throw C7
um it was like a mutual blunder and then
he very quickly blundered here
yeah and now this just wins a piece for
you yeah I still think it's like a very
difficult technical task if he defends
it well but
um
but it's probably quite difficult to
defend
Fabiano uh Levon came to the studio he
said this is probably the thing that he
enjoys most just 960. no preparation
communication with his peers before the
round is it the same for you as well
yeah I do enjoy it I mean he's told me
before that he he would love to see more
uh just 960.
like many times he's he's told me this
so so I knew that that he really loves
his format
um I don't share quite the same love for
it but I do enjoy it I mean it's it's a
nice
um
yeah a nice diversion from you know
regular chess where you have to prepare
a lot or not not so much in wrapping in
Blitz but still you know openings are a
huge part of the game in here that
doesn't play a part I mean opening is
huge but not opening preparation doesn't
really play a part at all I was out of
book uh if I moved to in every single
every single game tonight
Fabiano congratulations we'll see you in
the next couple of days and our
congratulations as well Fabi as he
scores two and a half out of three but
that's not enough for first place as
Napo three from three very impressive
Anastasia yes very impressive result and
we've had so many decisive games so much
fun how many decisive games yeah we had
11 games yeah decisive game and one
round 15 out of 15 years and the one
around there was five out of the five
not bad at all I remember the so a bit
of three and these are early days early
early days congratulations but where's
Anastasia is kind of happy with her pick
but no nepo yes dude you took my pick
and you you you're an influencer
Christian I we discussed it at the
beginning of the show we're both going
to pick Wesley I thought you were going
to give me a good pick what's happening
six games to go don't don't fight don't
fight don't fight final thoughts of this
very eventful uh first round of first
day of play absolutely very eventful and
one thing that strikes me as odd a
little bit is the Forum that we're
seeing Hikaru in right now losing two
games especially in this time format and
this type of Chess I find a bit striking
and a little bit odd but he definitely
still has a lot of games to go and a lot
of games try to recover guys we're going
to have a lot of exciting games for the
next couple of days absolutely Christian
the only time will tell what will happen
after years any Hikaru needs to find
someone to start analyzing the games
we'll see maybe everybody needs to
change his strategy according to what
happened today
Anastasia your first day of broadcasting
with the show it's been great to have
you on thank you so much for coming you
promise to come tomorrow yes I promise
yes
in that case we're gonna say goodbye to
everybody thank you for sharing your day
with us join us tomorrow uh with
Christian Anastasia myself we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited